Ich glaube, das ist nach wie vor der längste Sendungsopener, den Fritz zu bieten hat. Der kommt hier immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat und ist der Opener fürs Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Das heißt der Blue Moon, wo Leute aus dem Chaos Radio und da kann man es nahestehende Organisationen nennen, zu Gast sind, um über ein Technikthema zu debattieren mit sich, mit uns, mit euch. Heute zu Gast hier bei mir, Markus Richter, ist Erdgeist. Guten Tag und guten Abend.
Wunderschön, guten Abend.
Vom Chaos Computer Club und Alex Molang von den Freifunkern. Guten Abend. Was das genau ist, klären wir dann auch noch im Laufe der Sendung, in der es heute um W-Lan gehen soll. Das ist ja erstmal so kein großes Problem, denkt ihr wahrscheinlich. Wenn ihr nicht gerade in Brandenburg lebt, wo es noch gar kein Internet gibt, denkt ihr euch ja kein Problem. Hab ich doch W-Lan, hat doch jeder mittlerweile. Aber genau daran liegt es, weil mit W-Lan kann man viel Fug antreiben und auch viel Unfug. Und gerade letztens gab es eine Urteil, wo es darum ging, wer hat eigentlich die Verantwortung darüber, was jemand anstellt über ein W-Lan, das offen ist. Und da zieht sich natürlich die Frage hinterher, hmm, sollen wir unser W-Lan alle auflassen oder alle zumachen? Und dann gibt es Leute, die sagen so und es gibt Leute, die sagen so. Und heute wollen wir von euch zum Beispiel auch hören, was ihr dazu sagt.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Das ist die Nummer, die ihr anrufen könnt während der ganzen Sendung. Wir wollen jetzt aber erstmal ein bisschen eine kleine Einführung ins Thema machen, und ich gebe ab an den Herren Erdgeist mit der Frage, was zur Hölle ist denn eigentlich das Problem?
Das Problem ist, dass wenn du bis vor kurzem noch in den Laden gegangen bist, gesagt hast, ich möchte bei mir zu Hause W-Lan haben, haben sie dir eine kleine Box in die Hand gedrückt. Diese kleine Box hast du bei dir dann an deinen DSL-Router angeschlossen. Und dann konntest du zu Hause dein Notebook aufklappen und hattest überall beim Duschen, in der Küche, im Bett hattest du Internet und konntest da Nachrichten klicken, deine Mails klicken und alles war super. Und das blöde ist, dass diese W-Lan-Wellen einfach nicht bei deiner Haustür aufhören, sondern deine Nachbarn sehen die Dinge auch. Und vorbeilaufende Passanten, die können, wenn sie mal kurz ihre Mails ablesen wollen, dann können sie auch ihre Mails über dein W-Lan-Netzwerk lesen. Hört sich erstmal auch nicht schlimm an. Man kann aber nicht nur seine Mails abrufen über das W-Lan-Netzwerk, sondern man kann auch, was man sonst bei sich zu Hause macht, so Filme runterladen.
Moment mal, da ist doch irgendetwas.
Musik mit seinen Freunden tauschen. Da begann dann das Problem, dass der Letzte, der identifizierbar ist, bist du. Das heißt, wenn dann irgendwer daherkommt, mein Film, mein Musikstück, was du da gerade zum Upload angeboten hast, dann stehen die bei dir vor der Tür und sagen, lasst das mal bitte. Wenn nicht, dann schicken wir dir unsere ganze Anwaltsmeute auf den Hals und dann wird das ganz teuer für dich.
Also das ist dann der eine Extremfall. Ich lasse meinen W-Lan total auf, sodass jeder mitmachen darf. Und wenn irgendwas über diesen Internetanschluss passiert, dann ist das rausfindbar und das ist halt das Letzte, was rausfindbar ist. Warum gibt es eigentlich noch nicht so einen Logging-Mechanismus, dass man sagt, okay, meine Route zeichnet auf, wer wann ist und ich kann nachweisen, dass der Rechner mit der bestimmten Adresse gar nicht zu meinem Haushalt gehört? Wäre das nicht eine Möglichkeit, das Ganze problemlos zu erledigen?
Das wäre wahrscheinlich eine schöne Möglichkeit, das Problemlos zu erledigen. Das Problem ist nur, dass du dann als Störer giltst. Das heißt, das ist dein Funknetzwerk und du hast jemanden im Zugang verschafft ins Internet und der hat da dann Blödsinn angestellt und deswegen bist du dann erstmal haftbar, weil du hast halt das Werkzeug zur Verfügung gestellt und der hat das verhindern können.
Nee, das meine ich ja sozusagen. In Zukunft schalte ich dieses Ding an, das zeichnet auf, welche Rechner ganz genau unterwegs sind. Das kann man ja auch sozusagen sehen. Beim Rechner ja noch so eigene Bezeichnungen, Mac-Adressen. Und wenn dann jemand kommt und sagt, hey, über dein W-Lan ist getauscht, dann kann ich sagen, ja, das mag ja sein, aber nicht mit meinem Gerät. Hier guck, meine Geräte ist diese Liste, die waren da nicht im Netz unterwegs und ja, ist doch super.
Naja, das kannst du nicht unbedingt tun, weil es gibt ja immer noch das Fernmeldegeheimnis. Und wenn da jetzt jemand deinen W-Lan-Router benutzt, dann gilt dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis. Also du darfst ja auch nicht in den Datenstrom reingucken. Schon gar nicht du selbst, weil dann brichst du dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis. Deshalb ist es etwas schwierig. Und dann ist halt das andere Thema, das auch noch nicht reicht. Dann weißt du jetzt, wer bei dir gesurft hat. Aber davon kann man auch noch nicht zuordnen, wer das jetzt wirklich war. Weil dafür müsste man auf der anderen Seite noch viel mehr Daten erheben. Du musstest Daten erheben. Und mit diesem ganzen Daten erheben, kommen wir dann in Bereiche, wo es nicht mehr...
Ich müsste dann wie bei mir einen Log auf meinem Server anlegen. Und dieses Log würde ich dann einfach selber unter meiner Fruchtel behalten, könnte natürlich beliebig...
Das wäre dann quasi private Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Nee, nicht nur. Das wäre einfach, die Polizei kommt bei mir vorbei oder der Rechtsinhaber kommt bei mir vorbei und sagt, wer war's denn? Dann produziere ich ein auf meinem Router befindliches Log, wo ich natürlich selbst drauf Zugriff habe und es beliebig manipulieren kann. Also das ist natürlich keine Möglichkeit. Da käme man dann gleich wieder... Vor allem die MAC-Adressen sind ja auch beliebig fälschbar. Vor allem bei Funknetzwerkarten kann man ja als jeder Belieber auftauchen. Also müsste man dann gleich so weit gehen, dass man kryptographisch gesichert dann signiert, dass man dieses Paket wirklich war. Und dann kommen wir da in Teufels Küche und dann kannst du gleich das wieder zumachen.
Okay, soviel zu der einfachen Idee, die nicht funktioniert. Bevor wir jetzt in dieses Detail einsteigen, wer jetzt für was verantwortlich ist, haben wir heute Alex hier von den Freifunkern, weil man könnte sagen, das ist das andere Extrem zu, ich verschlüssel mal ein WLAN und nutze es nur ganz alleine. Alex, erklär doch mal kurz Freifunk, was ist das für jemanden, der es noch nicht gehört hat?
Okay, ein bisschen schwierig in kurz zu erklären, aber die Idee ist, dass ich...
Also wir haben bis Mitternacht, das wäre allerdings schick, wenn du ein bisschen vorher fertig werden würdest.
Ich gebe mir Mühe. Also deswegen gibt es halt diese Freifunkgeschichte, da hat man so einen kleinen Router, da kann man sein DSL anschließen und dann gibt dieser Router das Netz nicht nur in der Nachbarschaft frei, sondern wenn der Nachbar sagt, ich möchte jetzt irgendwie mehr Netz, dann kann er sich einen kleinen Freifunkrouter hinstellen und der trägt das Signal weiter. Und plötzlich hört der dritte Nachbar das Signal und der sagt, oh cool, jetzt kriege ich das Signal, stelle ich mir auch so einen Freifunkrouter hin und der trägt es wieder weiter. Und das machen ungefähr 600 Leute in Berlin, also 600 von diesen kleinen Kisten, die das Signal immer weiter tragen und immer weiter tragen und halt dir deine Datenpakete zum nächstgelegenen DSL-Anschluss hinreichen. Und auf die Art und Weise kannst du halt nicht nur deine unmittelbare Nachbarschaft mit Internet versorgen, sondern auch noch die Nachbarschaft drum herum. Weil jeder, der mitmacht, trägt es weiter. Das ist so ein großes Virus, was sich dann über die Stadt erschränkt.
Das hört sich jetzt glaub ich für jemanden, der nicht genau weiß, dass es ein bisschen schlimmer ist. Ein Virus verbreitet sich über die Stadt. Aber man kann sich im Prinzip doch vorstellen, wie ein großes Firmennetzwerk. Das ist ja auch nicht nur ein WLAN Access Point da, sondern ganz viele. Es gibt in der Stadt verschiedene WLAN-Router, die alle miteinander kommunizieren. Das ist alles ein großes Netz.
Genau, und es wächst organisch. Und es ist auch ziemlich schwer zu kontrollieren. Jeder kann da mitmachen. Der hat dann so einen kleinen Plastik-Router. Und da kommt dann so eine freie Software drauf.
Genau, das ist der Punkt, wo ich schon mal nachfragen möchte, wenn Nerds sagen, jeder kann da mitmachen. Und da kommt so eine kleine Software auf den Router rauf. Wie viel Aufwand ist das? Und wie viel Ahnung muss man davon haben?
Man muss in der Lage sein, wenn man in Berlin ist, entweder am Mittwoch in die C-Base zu kommen, sinnvollerweise am ersten Mittwoch des Monats. Da ist der Einsteiger-Workshop. Oder man schafft es irgendwie zu den lokalen Treffpunkten in Kreuzberg, in Friedrichshain, in Hohenschönhausen. Man muss tatsächlich eine Webseite lesen können. Die Kiezfunka treffen sich dann auf dem Helmholzplatz am Montagabend. Und dort trifft man ganz reale Menschen. Und die sagen, ja komm, ist doch alles gar nicht so schlimm. Guck mal hier, kaufst du dir den Router. Wir haben da sogar schon mal einen, den du erst mal haben kannst gegen Kleinfund, bis du dann deinen eigenen hast. Und dann helfen wir dir, das Ding darauf zu spielen. Und dann ist das alles auch gar nicht mehr so schlimm. Dann sind das plötzlich Menschen und dann macht man das gemeinsam und bastelt da und am Schluss hat man sehr, sehr häufig so ein kleines Gerät, da fällt Internet raus. Oder man hat so ein kleines Gerät, da speist man Internet rein. Weil man sagt, hey, cool, freier Zugang zu Wissen und Bildung irgendwie für alle. Das finde ich ganz toll. Und überhaupt die digitale Spaltung. Und wer weiß denn, meine Nachbarin kann sich das sowieso nicht leisten. Und zum Beispiel meine Nachbarn, das sind zwei Studenten, die haben gar kein Internet. Und die haben jetzt Internet auch über Freifunk. Und das Tolle ist, wir können auch noch untereinander irgendwie Dinge machen.
Okay, jetzt also ich nehme in ein Wort, es ist kein Problem, wenn man sich dafür interessiert. Man muss aber ein bisschen Zeit investieren. Also sagen, es ist noch nicht so irgendwie, geh hin, lass mir das irgendwo draufspielen, stell es hin, dann funktioniert alles. Ich muss schon sozusagen ein gewisses Grundinteresse mitbringen. Das ist noch ein bisschen was zu machen. Wie ist es denn auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich sozusagen jetzt nicht selber so ein Ding hinstellen will, sondern wenn ich einfach mal dieses Netz, das ist ja eh schon da, konnte ich mir denken, ich nutze das jetzt einfach. Ist das so einfach, wie sich in einen W-Lang-Café einzuklinken oder schwieriger?
Das ist relativ einfach. Das kommt natürlich darauf an, wie du, der das Internet anbietest, das eingestellt hat. Ich stelle es zum Beispiel so ein, dass meine Nachbarn das alles auch ohne Gerät kriegen. Das heißt, du klappst der Notebook auf, du klickst auf das Freifunkding und dann machst du deinen Browser auf und dann wirst du umgeleitet. Dann kommst du auf eine Webseite, die liegt auf dem Router, und diese Webseite sagt, hallo, das hier ist ein Freifunk-Access-Point und der wurde aufgestellt von bla bla bla und irgendwie der möchte irgendwie, dass du auch ins Internet kommst, aber das ist an folgende Bedingungen geknüpft. Dann steht da meistens so was wie, bitte macht doch bitte kein Filesharing und keine illegalen Handlungen und kein unnötiges Streaming, weil hier teilen sich 30, 40 Leute einen Anschluss und das ist einfach nicht fair. Und wenn du dann auf Accept klickst, dann hast du für eine Stunde Netzzugang und nach einer Stunde kommt diese Seite wieder und sagt, lieber User, das wäre ganz cool, wenn du mitmachst. Und am Montag treffen wir uns auch im Platzhaus und jetzt kannst du durch einmal klicken, nochmal wieder eine Stunde mitmachen. Und so kannst du irgendwie mitmachen. Und wenn du dann da wohnst, dann überlegst du dir, gehst du doch mal zu dem Treffen und kaufst diese 30 Euro und beschäftigst dich damit ein bisschen. Aber du musst halt statt Geld Zeit investieren.
Ich war anscheinend lange nicht mehr dem Versuch erlegen, ein Freifunknetz zu nutzen, weil als ich das damals rollierte, musste man noch eine extra Software auf seinem Rechner installieren. Das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so.
Ja, das ist so ein altes Berliner Dogma, was inzwischen gelöst ist. Die Leipziger in Freifunk Leipzig, die haben das schon immer so gemacht, wie ich das gerade beschrieben habe. Und die haben für eine viel kleinere Stadt genauso viele Access Points. Sind also deutlich erfolgreicher damit gewesen.
Woran liegt das?
Wir haben als Hotspot-Anbieter keinen Fuß an den Boden gekriegt. Und in Berlin sind wir jetzt inzwischen auch da angekommen, dass wir sagen, okay, wir machen das auch mal für alle auf. Aber das hängt auch so ein bisschen davon ab, wo man ist. Also die einen machen das mehr, die anderen machen das weniger. Das ist ja immer so eine bunte Mischung, diese Freifunker.
So, und jetzt sind wir heute hier zusammengekommen um über dieses W-Lan aufmachen oder nicht oder überhaupt. Und was ist das Problem? Weil es neulich einen Gerichtsentscheid gab. Gibt es da eine klare Antwort? Worum ging es da eigentlich? Was passiert?
Also in dem Gerichtsurteil ging es darum, dass da jemand in den Urlaub gefahren ist. Und während er im Urlaub war, hat ein Passant oder ein Nachbar ein Musikstück runtergeladen. Und der Rapper, der das eigentlich verkaufen wollte, der fand das doof und wollte dann... Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich bei diesen Musikern nicht so aus. Ich hab den Namen auch schon wieder vergessen. Aber der Punkt war, dass der Urlaubende dann einfach gemeint, ich war nicht zu Hause, ich kanns nicht gewesen sein, ich kanns auch nachweisen. Und der Rechteinhaber meinte, nee, aber es ist egal, das war dein W-Lan und deswegen bist du derjenige, an dem wir uns halten. Und das BGH hat dann jetzt entschieden, dass wenn du bei dir zu Hause so eine Kiste hinstellst und W-Lan unverschlüsselt anbietest, dann haftest du erst mal bis zu einer bestimmten Grenze, die irgendwie 2008 festgelegt worden ist, so 100 Euro pro Werk, solange es nicht gewerbsmäßig oder besonders schwerer Fall ist. Und ansonsten bist du dazu angehalten, generell dein Funknetzwerk zu Hause zu sichern auf eine geeignete Maßnahme, die zum Zeitpunkt des Kaufs des Geräts dem Stand der Technik entsprach. Das heißt, du wirst dazu angehalten, wenn du nicht auf die Finger bekommen möchtest, dein Netzwerk zu Hause zu verschlüsseln.
Okay, wie es mit Rechtsachen ist, es gibt ja immer nicht so die ganz klaren Antworten auf die Frage, was bedeutet dieses Urteil eigentlich. Ich habe kurz nachdem dieses Urteil gefällt wurde, das war am 12. Mai, glaube ich, also irgendwie Anfang Mai auf jeden Fall, mit dem Rechtsanwalt Jan Strunk telefoniert. Der hat sich damals mit diesem Fall beschäftigt. Wir haben mal versucht, genau auseinanderzuklamüsern, was eigentlich sagt dieses Urteil jetzt. Und ich wollte natürlich als erstes von ihm wissen, gibt es jetzt eine genaue Entscheidung so oder irgendwie doch nicht?
Eine typische Antwort, es kommt drauf an. Seit Mittwoch wissen wir, oder wir wissen es nicht, aber es ist ein kleines bisschen mehr Klarheit reingebracht worden in die grundsätzlichen Voraussetzungen, unter denen ich hafte. Und man kann es ganz platt ausdrücken, in dem Moment, wo ich einfach nur ein Funknetz aufbaue, so wie es mir angeliefert wird, keiner der Einstellungen vornehme und einfach drauf lossurfe und dann den Urlaubsfahrer nützt es mir seit Mittwoch nichts mehr, wenn ich dann hinterher sagen kann, okay, ich bin es nicht gewesen, ich kann auch beweisen, dass ich es nicht war. Denn dann greift so der Bundesgerichtshof die Haftung, die sogenannte Störerhaftung für fremde Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Das heißt, ich muss wiederum kümmern, dass mein W-Lan in irgendeiner Art und Weise geschützt ist?
Ja, die genauen Kriterien dafür, die sind natürlich jetzt noch nicht so ganz festgezurrt, zumal das Urteil ja in der Begründung noch nicht vorliegt. Das, was die Bundesrichter dort wohl gesagt haben, ist im Kern, also ich muss zumindest etwas tun, was über den Auslieferungszustand hinausgeht, sprich ich muss dann zumindest auch entsprechend ein Passwort einrichten, das jetzt nicht dem werkzeitig Ausgelieferten entspricht, weil das kennt ohnehin jeder, der dann auch mal vielleicht Böses treibt und das wäre also zu einfach. Und der Bundesgerichtshof hat auch gesagt, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht die Pflicht des W-Landetreibers, dass er jetzt permanent, vielleicht auch mit gewissen Kosten verbunden, da Sicherungsaufwand betreibt. Es geht im Kern darum, dass man dort zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man es in Betrieb nimmt, etwas mehr tut als einfach nur die Kiste auspacken.
Man hat jetzt im Zusammenhang mit dem Urteil immer gelesen, naja, falls sich das doch ereilt, dann kann es höchstens 100 Euro teuer werden. Stimmt das denn?
Das ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder so eine Geschichte, die je nach Betrachtungsweise, von welcher Seite man sich dem ganzen nähert, sehr aufmerksam verfolgt wird. Also der entscheidende Punkt bei der Geschichte ist, und das muss man einfach wissen, dieses Urteil befasst sich mit einem Sachverhalt, der aus seiner Zeit stammt, als es die Abmahnpauschale, die wir seit 2008 haben, im Urheberrechtsgesetz noch nicht gab. Und das Gericht hatte dementsprechend wenig Anlass, sich überhaupt mit der Frage zu befassen, wird es eventuell ein bisschen billiger. Da ging es jetzt hier ja konkret nur darum, sind die Abmahnkosten bezüglich des Unterlassungsanspruchs, sind die einfach zu bezahlen oder nicht? Und das antwortet ganz klar ja, was aber interessant ist, und es gibt auch die Pressemitteilung her, ganz offensichtlich geht der Senat, der für diese Fragen zuständig ist, davon aus, dass die Regelung, die es im Urheberrechtsgesetz jetzt gibt seit 2008, nämlich maximal 100 Euro, Kostenpauschale für solche Fälle auszusprechen, dass die wohl gelten soll. Aber ist es jetzt für alle Fälle so, wo Urheberrecht verletzt wird, oder gibt es dann wiederum auch Einschränkungen, dass man sagt irgendwie, naja, natürlich nicht für alle Fälle so, es ist aber exakt jetzt für einen Fall, der sich so abspielt wie der, von dem wir gerade reden.
Und da ging es um ein einziges Musikstück?
Ja, da geht es um ein einziges Musikstück, aber es geht ja auch um die Frage, wenn ich überhaupt nicht weiß, was dort passiert, und ich hafte jetzt auf die Unterlassung dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung, dann haben wir ja einen Bereich, wo man zumindest sagen kann, dass derjenige, den es betrifft, es wohl nicht geschäftlich macht. Und dass das eben auch eine Geschichte ist, die man eventuell unter diese Vorschrift bekommt, außerhalb des geschäftlichen Verkehrs muss das stattfinden. Das muss ein einfach gelagerter Fall sein, und die Rechtsverletzung darf nicht so erheblich sein. Natürlich, wenn es um die Frage geht, es ist nicht nur ein Titel, sondern sind ganz Almen, oder es sind Filme oder Ähnliches, da wird im Detail natürlich einiges noch durch die Rechtsprechung zu klären sein.
Das heißt also, wenn jemand über meinen Wähler nicht nur einen einzigen Song, sondern hoffentlich Zeug tauscht, dann kann es auch teurer werden. Wie ist es denn eigentlich, wir haben jetzt gerade die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, wenn jemand in meinen W-Lan einbricht, egal ob ich es gesichert habe oder nicht. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen, ich finde es eigentlich eine total coole Idee, dass mein W-Lan offen ist für alle, weil ich diesen Gedanken mag. Und es gibt auch Cafés, die haben ein offenes W-Lan. Was ist denn mit denen? Dürfen die das jetzt einfach nicht mehr machen?
Natürlich darf man das tun. Das Entscheidende ist natürlich bei der ganzen Geschichte. Und darüber verhält sich das Urteil natürlich nicht. Wenn ich eine Situation habe, in der ich von vornherein sage, gut, ich hab jetzt hier, was soll ich, eine soziale Ader oder ich betreibe ein Internetcafé oder noch profaner, auch innerhalb der eigenen Familie oder auch studentische Wohngemeinschaft, wo man sich das teilt, dann bedarf es natürlich jetzt vor allem auch im Licht dieser Entscheidungen gewisser Kriterien, nach denen sich dann möglicherweise die Frage beantworten lässt, was ist zumutbar, also was muss ich konkret tun, damit ich abgesichert bin, wenn irgendjemand meiner Mitbewohner oder meiner Gäste Unfug treibt. Das ist überhaupt noch nicht geklärt und das ist ein grundsätzliches Problem, das sich auf Grundlage dieser Entscheidung noch nicht lösen lässt.
Bam, das Einzige, was ich mitgenommen habe von diesem Rechtsanwalt ist folgender Satz, no risk, no fun. Und wenn er mich fragt, ganz ehrlich, wenn man sich das so anhört, dann würde ich doch sagen, naja, mach ich meine W-Lan einfach zu, weil dann kriegen sie halt für keinen Ärger. Ist ja auch relativ einfach, kann jeder machen. Und dann ist es halt nur für mich und es wäre halt schöner, aber meine Güte, irgendwie ich mir so eine komische Abmahnung einfange. Lasst sich das mal lieber bleiben. Es geht unter anderem heute auch darum, was ihr davon haltet.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110 Und anrufen könnt ihr hier ganz ehrlich, ohne in Gefahr zu laufen, abgemahnt zu werden. Versprochen. So, jetzt hab ich schon gesagt, ich mach meinen W-Lan zu. Erdgeist ist hier vom Chaos Computer Club und Alex von den Freifunkern. Ich denke, ihr seht das naturgemäß anders.
Na, man kann sich das so vorstellen, wie derjenige in deiner Nachbarschaft, der um sein Haus herum die allerhöchsten Mauern gezogen hat, wo die krassesten Schlossanlagen sich befinden, ist eigentlich nicht so der sympathischste Nachbar. Auf der anderen Seite sind die, die gleich bei dir klingeln, mit Brot und Salz während du eingezogen bist und dir irgendwie ja, komm, wir setzen dich bei uns im Vorgarten, wir haben eine nette Wanda, kannst mit unserer Katze spielen. Es ist irgendwie ein anderer Lebensentwurf, einfach die Welt nicht so bedrohungszentrisch zu sehen. Die Nachbarn sind nicht die Bösen, die dir einfach in den Vorgarten Häufchen machen wollen, sondern mit den Nachbarn lebst du zusammen. Und auch im Zweifel sind die Leute, die bei dir zuhause vorbeilaufen und dann weder zum Mail lesen mitbenutzen wollen, sind einfach nur arme Wanderer, die einfach ihre Mail lesen wollen und nicht irgendwas Böses im Internet, aus dem irgendwie nur, offensichtlich wohl nur Böses reingetragen wird und nur Böses rauskommt. Ich persönlich mag einfach diese bedrohungszentrische Weltsicht nicht, die jetzt irgendwie alles zunageln, alles zunageln sagt, sondern ich will erstmal ganz naiv davon ausgehen, dass die Menschen gut sind und dass ich den Menschen erstmal entgegenkomme und sage, hier hast du Internet.
Aber dass du sagen, das setzt voraus, dass du im Zweifel auch einen Kauf nimmst, dass irgendjemand Unfug treibt und dass du dann dran bist, um es mal platt zu sagen. Also mit einer Abmahnung wegen, wie heißt das dann, mit Störerhaftung dann so 100 Euro, wenn es glimpflicher abgeht oder vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr zahlen musst?
Wir bewegen uns in einer Gesellschaft, in der man eigentlich für fast alles inzwischen verklagt werden kann und sich da einfach dann, ja für mich ist es keine Gefahr, sondern einfach so ein kleines Risiko und in meinem Freundeskreis passiert das auch einfach nicht. Ich hab meinen W-Lan irgendwie seit 10 Jahren offen, seitdem das irgendwie damals passiert ist. Ich war irgendwie kleiner Nerd und als ich das erste Mal mit meinem PDA, mit dem, was war das damals, als ich mit diesem I-Pack irgendwie rumstand und hinten da so einen fetten Cradle dran hatte und da Funknetzwerk plötzlich in meiner Hand hatte und ich unterwegs W-Lan hatte, das war einfach, das war göttlich. Da ging mir so ein ungeschriebener Nerdtraum einfach in Erfüllung. Und wie dieses W-Lan ist eigentlich ein Menschenrecht, irgendwie unterwegs Internet zu haben und ich möchte nicht, dass es jetzt von Hotspot-Betreibern dann unterminiert wird, die einfach Angst schüren davor, dass ja so viele böse Dinge passieren. Für mich sind das alles anekdotische Geschichten, die ich höre von Leuten, die da wirklich dann auch was erlebt haben. Also ich hab irgendwie in der ganzen Zeit keinen einzigen Brief bekommen von niemanden. Weder hat jemand Musik getauscht, noch irgendwas Illegales. Aus meinem komplett offenen W-Lan gemacht. Und ich hatte auch glaube ich nur ein einziges Mal das Problem, dass jemand Kino.to die ganze Zeit so Filme runtergeladen hat. Und dann musste ich da ihm mal Bescheid sagen, dass er doch das mal sein lässt. Und ansonsten, mein W-Lan ist offen und meine Nachbarn freuen sich. Ich habe jetzt auch durch Zufall von einer Kommilitonin gehört, dass eine Kommilitonin von ihr durch Zufall in meinem Haus wohnt und sich darüber riesig gefreut hat, dass ein Nachbar das Netz mit dem Namen Rudolf einfach jedem zur Verfügung stellt. Und wer ist er total nett und so. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja den kenne ich. Und man tut einfach Menschen was Gutes.
Als ich in Hamburg war, habe ich mein W-Lan offen gehabt natürlich. Und dann ging diese ganze Freifunkgeschichte los. Dann haben wir die riesigen Antennen aufs Dach gebaut. Und damit auch die ganze Nachbarschaft das kriegt. Und dann haben wir da tatsächlich auch ein paar Geräte aufgestellt. Das Ganze am Rande von Hamburg, einen Kilometer entfernt. Das ist natürlich nicht wie in Friedrichshain oder so, aber ein Anfang. Und jetzt wohne ich in Friedrichshain und habe gar keinen DSL-Anschluss. Ich habe noch so ein bisschen UMTS fürs Handy, aber bei mir in der Bude gibt es Freifunk. Das gibt einen Ablink, der ist irgendwie die Straße runter. Und das geht dann über einen weiteren Nachbarn, zu dem Nachbarn, zu dem Nachbarn. Und das ist zwar nicht berauschend schnell, aber es funktioniert gut und es funktioniert zuverlässig. Und da freue ich mich natürlich tierisch, dass der sagt, ja, ich habe irgendwie noch irgendwie die Zivilcourage und sage irgendwie, das Risiko gehe ich ein. Und auf der anderen Seite gehe ich es halt in Hamburg ein, wo immer noch der DSL-Anschluss läuft und nicht nur die WG, sondern halt auch die Nachbarschaft versorgt.
Das heißt so, das ist auch jederzeit Wider tun?
Ja, aber selbstverständlich. Ich denke, das ist einfach ganz wichtig, dass es auch ganz viele Leute tun. Es kann nicht sein, dass das Internet irgendwie ein Privileg ist. Es gibt einfach so viele Möglichkeiten, warum man kein Internet hat. Man ist für einen Monat in der Stadt, man hat einen Schufa-Eintrag, man ist nicht gewünscht von den Telcos. Es gibt dort vielleicht gar keine freien Leitungen mehr. Und irgendwie geben ist seliger daneben.
Es ist eine Philosophiefrage, wenn man euch beiden zuhört. Ihr seid technisch im Plan, im Stoff. Erdgeister gerade erzählt, wenn da jemand die ganze Zeit rumsurft und ihr euch das Netz langsamer macht, sagst du mal Bescheid, das Netz da voraus. Du hast das technische Wissen, das mitzukriegen überhaupt. Der normale User, der sein WLAN-Router aufmacht, sagt halt, oh nein, mein Netz ist langsam, was ist passiert? Zur Anekdote, um mal zu zeigen, dass es das gibt. Ich hab tatsächlich von einem Kumpel, hat die Mutter schreiben bekommen, ja, sie haben unter ihrer IP-Adresse einen Film in einem Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk getauscht. Und die Reaktion der Mutter war so Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk, was soll das denn sein? Und es war also völlig unklar, wie das passiert sein soll, weil sie das natürlich nicht gemacht hat. Und da hab ich dann gefragt, aber guck doch mal, ob der Router offen ist. Na ja, war er. Und das ist tatsächlich auch die einzige Möglichkeit, wie das halt stattfinden kann. Das ist halt die Frage, okay, dann ist es halt noch gefährlich. Und ich hab noch eine zweite Anekdote von einer Frau, wo ich mal zu Besuch war, und ich hatte so W-Lan. Und das war so eigentlich eine dicke Leitung, aber es ging eher so GPRS, also so Handy-Internet, so die von der Geschwindigkeit her. Und dann haben wir mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt, haben das W-Lan mal zugemacht. Und dann stellt sich heraus, ja, da hat halt die ganze Zeit jemand drüber gesurft und bitterrand gemacht. Das kriegt die natürlich nicht raus. Wie denn auch? Sie stellt sich das Ding halt ins Wohnzimmer und dann soll das halt funktionieren. Was ist also die Empfehlung für Leute, die jetzt keinen Plan haben?
Naja, wir haben den Erdgeist, der ist der Evil-Überhacker und der macht das einfach. Und ich krieg das auch noch hin. Und ich kann da natürlich auch sehen, okay, der macht das, der macht das, der ist das. Das muss man natürlich auch wieder gesagt ein bisschen aufpassen, da gibt es ja das Fernmeldegeheimnis. Ansonsten kann man das natürlich outsourcen. Das heißt, da gibt es den Sven Ohler. Sven Ohler ist der Mensch, der auch die erste Version der Freifunk-Firmware entwickelt hat. Das ist diese Open Source Ding, was auf diesen Routern läuft. Der hat sich angesichts dieser BGH-Gewurteilsgeschichte, das kam ja alles immer drohender, wie so ein Gewitter, und jetzt ist es doch alles nicht so schlimm, wie wir denken, angefangen und hat so einen Skript zusammengehackt. Das macht Folgendes, das guckt so ein bisschen in dein Internet-Traffic und das zählt, wie viele Verbindungen da so auftauchen. Das sagt sich, okay, ich weiß das zwar nicht genau, aber da werden jetzt so ein paar Grenzen überschritten. Dieser Benutzer macht wahrscheinlich gerade Filesharing. Und was das macht, ist, das macht dann erst mal dicht und lenkt den Benutzer auf eine Webseite um, wo drauf steht, lieber User, wir glauben, dass du da gerade was machst, das eigentlich gar nicht so im Sinne des Freifunks ist, weil irgendwie wir teilen uns hier unsere Ressourcen und außerdem irgendwie ist da so eine Verantwortungsnummer anlaufen. Lieber User, lass das doch bitte. Und wenn du jetzt hier auf ich will aber wenigstens surfen klickst, dann kannst du zumindest wieder web surfen und E-Mail senden und noch auf deine Server connecten. Aber das war es dann auch so. Und der Betreiber des Uplink-Notens, also der, der dafür dann zur Haftung gezogen würde, der kriegt eine Mail, wo im Prinzip drinsteht, User bla bla bla hat das getriggert und User bla bla bla kann halt auch irgendwie eine E-Mail verschicken und dann kommen die normalerweise ziemlich schnell in Kontakt. Und dann kann man sagen, du böser User, das ist aber nicht in Ordnung irgendwie. Wir machen doch hier gemeinsam und machst doch alles kaputt, was wir hier gemeinsam aufbauen und stellen mal vor, die bösen Anwälte kommen und wollen an uns Geld verdienen. Deshalb lasst das doch mal lieber. Und wir haben das jetzt seit ein paar Wochen im Betrieb in Berlin. Und das funktioniert, das wird dann ein paar Mal getriggert. Dann sprechen die mit den Leuten. Und seitdem passiert da eigentlich nichts mehr. Die merken dann alle, oh, okay, das ist halt kein kommerzieller Anbieter, sondern das ist dann Community Network. Und dann muss man halt auch mal ein bisschen Community spielen, sonst geht das nicht.
Okay, dann wäre für mich immer die spannende Frage noch, also jedes Problem, das wir haben, hat sozusagen eine technische Lösung von euch. Ich glaube aber immer noch, dass es da draußen ganz viele Leute gibt, die sagen, ey, weißt du ja letztendlich, das ist mir lade, ich will zu Hause mein Netz haben, das mache ich zu, dann habe ich überhaupt gar keinen Ärger mehr, damit ist alles gut. Wie ihr das macht, würden wir gerne von euch wissen, unter 0331 70 97 110. Bevor wir aber weiter drüber reden, machen wir erstmal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder?
Mit Markus Richter und Erdgeist, guten Abend. Und Alex, der gerade schnell zum Mikrofon eilt, guten Abend. Und es geht heute um W-Lan und es geht um die Frage auf oder zu. Das wollen wir von euch wissen. Verschlüsselt ihr euer W-Lan oder nicht, ihr könnt gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 oder dieser Nummer. Und uns mal erzählen, wie ihr das macht mit eurem W-Lan. Die Frage war nämlich, es gab so ein Gerichtsurteil, da stand so drin, naja, also richtig schlimm kommt es nicht mehr, wenn jemand über euer W-Lan Unfug treibt, aber so ein bisschen seid ihr schon verantwortlich. Und Erdgeist und Alex haben erzählt, naja, W-Lan auf ist eine super Idee. Erdgeist macht sein eigenes W-Lan auf. Alex ist bei den Freifunkern, die machen gleich so ein ganz stattübergreifendes Netz und sagen, naja, im Prinzip nehmen wir das vielleicht in Kauf, wenn da irgendwas kommt oder werfen so ein bisschen Technik drauf, damit das nicht so schlimm ist, damit da keine Leute Falschherring betreiben. Meine Theorie ist, dass vielen Leuten das zu kompliziert ist, nicht einfach sagen, lass mich mit dem ganzen Kram in Ruhe, ich will zu Hause Internet, das ist mir egal, ob ich unterwegs Netz habe, da hab ich mein Handy, ich mach mein Netz zu und damit hat sich die Sache, dann kriege ich überhaupt keinen Ärger. Jetzt gab es ja diese Gerichtsentscheidung, wo quasi gesagt wird, also grundsätzlich ist der Typ, der beim W-Lan gehört, schon dafür zuständig, dass er das irgendwie sicher hält, dass er nicht jeder rein kann. Alex, haben irgendwie Freifunk, habt ihr da befreundete Rechtsanwälte oder sowas, die sich da mal mit diesem Urteil beschäftigt haben, um da zu gucken, ob das für euch auch was bedeuten könnte?
Ja, es ist so ein Paar, die kümmern sich und es gibt da diese Webseite, Freifunk statt Angst-Dee und die sagen im Prinzip so, wir wissen jetzt nicht viel mehr als vorher, wir haben noch keine schriftliche Begründung und alles, was wir wissen, ist, dass es auf 100 Euro gedeckelt ist. Ansonsten sind die Fragen bezüglich Freifunk immer noch ganz weit offen, weil es gibt da ja ganz viele unterschiedliche Ansichten. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, ja aber Freifunk ist auch nur ein Provider und die anderen sagen, ja wir sind kein Provider und wir sind dies und wir sind jenes und es gibt das Telemedien-Gesetz und das ist alles furchtbar kompliziert und effektiv wissen wir noch nichts. Wir wissen, wie gesagt, 100 Euro ist das Maximum und das für die einfachen Fälle und ansonsten können wir das noch nicht einschätzen, was das wirklich für eine Bedeutung hat.
Nichts genaues weiß man also nicht, könnte man sagen?
Ja, weil viele Freiburger sagen und die Anwälte sehen das ähnlich, das ist mehr als ein offener Access Point. Es gibt da diese Idee, ein freies Bürgerdatennetz zu betreiben und diese ganzen guten Dinge. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es dieses Rechtsgut mit dem Oeberrecht und dann gibt es eine Rechtsgüterabwägung. Wenn man es 100% verhindern will, dann müsste man es ja dicht machen. Damit könnte man aber auch kein offenes Bürgerdatennetz mehr betreiben. Da sind halt so zwei Güter, die abgewogen werden müssen. Die wurden bisher noch nicht von einem Gericht und schon gar nicht von einem BGH abgewogen. Deshalb sagen wir, solange das nicht explizit abgewogen wurde, ist es einfach nur ein schlecht gesicherter Access Point, der nicht mit der Intention, dass man dort Nachbarn mitsurfen lässt und der auch eine spezielle Software hat, um Nachbarn mitsurfen zu lassen, interessiert uns das schon. Aber es betrifft uns eigentlich nicht direkt.
Okay, das heißt, die Frage, ob das wirklich so ist, müsste sich herausstellen, wenn irgendjemand versucht, das durchzuklagen. Das ist also no risk, no fun, wie es der Anwalt im Interview Anfang gesagt hat.
Genau, es gibt da so ein paar Dinge, die jetzt aufgelaufen sind, weil jetzt gerade diese Mega-Abmahnwelle irgendwie läuft. Und da gibt es halt Dinge, die sind in der Kö und da wird gemacht. Aber da kann man halt jetzt im Moment noch nicht viel zu sagen, weil über ungelegte Eier kann man ja nicht gackern.
Gibt es denn in der Freifunkgemeinde selber, gab es da irgendwie seit dem Urteil so Stimmung, dass die Leute gesagt haben, lass uns lieber aufhören und vorsichtig sein? Oder seid ihr da ganz geschlossen der Meinung? Überhaupt finde ich irgendwie, du hast ja gesagt, 600 Knoten gibt es in Berlin, das heißt wahrscheinlich noch mehr Leute, die über euch mitmachen. Ihr könnt auch mal anrufen hier unter 0371 77 97 120. Mal erzählen, wie sie dazu gekommen sind und was sie da so machen. So, und wir haben jetzt hier Franjo am Telefon, tach. Hallo. Hallo, du wohnst in Dresden? Und hörst Chaosradio übers Internet nehme ich an? Und das heißt, du musst irgendwie im Netz sein, das machst du über ein WLAN?
Ne, das mache ich über einen ganz normalen UMTS-Stick, ja.
Okay, warum? Habt ihr keinen WLAN oder?
Na, ich sag mal, ich hab das aus bestimmten diversen Gründen mehr abgeschafft. Also mir selber meinen eigenen Provider hab ich, ja, ich hab da einfach kein Interesse mehr daran gehabt, richtig. Und hab mir dann aus diversen Gründen, wie gesagt, halt diesen UMTS-Stick zugelegt.
Okay, aber deine Frage, die du stellen willst, hat schon was mit WLANs zu tun.
Jaja, genau, genau. Und zwar ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt einen WLAN betreibe über mehrere, sag ich mal, Blöcke von Häusern, die auch komplett abgesichert sind, leider routerbedingt von der Firma und so weiter, nur durch WPA, jetzt einen Einbruch praktisch mitgesnifft habe, ausfindig gemacht und so weiter, wie muss ich dann weiter vorgehen, um dann ja praktisch jetzt erstmal die Sache offiziell zu machen.
Einen Einbruch physikalisch oder einen Einbruch in ein Netzwerk?
In ein Netzwerk.
Und wie hast du das festgestellt?
Das habe ich über, ich sag mal, ja, auf, über diverse Aktionen, die ich da gestartet habe, sag ich mal.
Wie, da saß einer in deinem Vorgarten auf der Bank und den hast du dabei beobachtet, wie er den Laptop aufgeklappt hat oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen, hast du deinen Logs nachgeguckt?
Ja, erstmal in den Logs, dann habe ich das auch ein bisschen mitgesnifft, die ganze Sache, und hab das halt auch mehrere Male nachgeprüft in dem Fall. Und bin da halt auch die ganzen Adressen und sowas ausfindig gemacht. Und weiß jetzt auch, an wen ich mich wenden soll, von der Person her, aber wie soll ich das vorgehen, vom rechtlichen Sinn her?
Ich weiß nicht, was versuchst du denn da gerade rechtlich durchzusetzen gegen die Niedigen, die du da erwischt hast?
Na ja, wenn ich jetzt die Person kenne.
Dann geh doch zu ihm hin und sag, lass das.
Ja, und wenn das nicht funktioniert, also wenn das wirklich im kriminellen Hintergrund herkommt.
Also was genau ist das Problem? Jemand surft über deinen W-Lan und treibt da Unfug?
Ja, Unfug in Form von Rapid Share und diversen Sachen, die man halt nicht über sein eigenes Netzwerk feststellen möchte.
Das Netz gehört dir?
Genau.
Und du möchtest nicht, dass er das macht?
Richtig.
Und wenn du ihm sagst, mach das nicht mehr, was passiert dann? Hast du also noch nicht versucht?
Ich glaube, das ist eher ein soziales Problem, was du da vielleicht einfach im Gespräch mit dem jungen Mann lösen solltest. Wenn nicht, dann kannst du auch versuchen, das auf technische Art und Weise durch eine MAC-Adressenfilter oder andere Maßnahmen, aber habe ich es richtig verstanden, dass du den Benutzern deines W-Lans hinterherspionierst und deren Datenverkehr dort reinguckst? Habe ich das richtig verstanden? Das hast du gerade so im Radio zugegeben. Dann würde ich mich vielleicht mit deinem Datenschutzbeauftragten mal unterhalten und das Mindset überprüfen lassen. Weil auch wenn die Leute deinen W-Lan benutzen, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass du da einfach den beliebig in ihren Traffic gucken kannst. Gibt da irgendwie Fernmeldegeheimnisse? Und finde ich jetzt nicht so richtig cool, was du da getan hast.
Nee, das ist ja auch nicht richtig. Also in dem Fall kenne ich immer die Person, das ist jetzt nicht Nachschniffen oder sowas. Es ist im Prinzip dann wie ein öffentliches Geständnis gewesen.
Ok, Franjo, ich fürchte, je mehr du erzählst, desto tiefer reitest du dich rein. Wir hatten heute in Hainun über Fettnäpfchen. Vielleicht hörst du den Podcast davon nochmal an. Und wir lassen das an dieser Stelle mal. Und wir halten fest, A, man snifft nicht einfach irgendwelchen Leuten hinterher. Das gehört sich nicht nur nicht, sondern das ist auch ungesetzlich. Und B, manche Dinge lassen sich klären, indem man die Leute einfach mal direkt anspricht. Okay, dann viel Spaß noch. Also nur nochmal so zum Allgemeinen. Das ist anscheinend sozusagen vielen Benutzern. Neuartiger Rundfunkempfangsgeräte, nicht so ganz klar. Also auch wenn es mein eigenes Netzwerk ist, sniff ich nicht so einfach hinterher. Das ist schon verboten. So wie es sozusagen anderen Leuten auch verboten ist, mich abzuhören, wenn ich telefoniere oder sowas. Also nicht mit dem Kopf nicken, Jungs.
Wir lauschen die einfach nur gebannt, weil das ist irgendwie einfach die Stimme der Impetus.
Können Sie jetzt auch sagen Ja oder Nein?
Wenn du technische Probleme diagnostizieren willst, dann kannst du da Werkzeuge ansetzen, aber auch nur dafür und auch nur in ganz begrenztem Umfang. Gehen so weit, dass wir darüber nachdenken, Werkzeuge einzusetzen, die automatisch pseudonymisieren oder anonymisieren, damit du technische Probleme debuggen kannst, ohne vertrauliche Daten angezeigt zu bekommen.
Das heißt, einerseits ist es nicht verboten, zu sniffen, also nicht generell, weil es ist einfach eine Technik, mit der ich möglicherweise Probleme in meinem Netzwerk klären kann. Andererseits, jemandem hinterherzulauschen, ist schon verboten. Okay, haben wir das festgehalten?
Ich fände es auch ganz spannend, wenn genau diese Technologien, die Freifunk da gerade baut, das ist ja keine Raketentechnologie. Das ist ja einfach diese Routerboxen, die man sich dann in seine Wohnung stellt. Die haben mehr Rechenpower als wahrscheinlich deine erste Computer, als meine erste Computer und als die erste Computer der meisten Leute hier am Radio. Und das bedeutet, dass der auch alles Mögliche machen kann. Der kann Heuristiken, also so schätzen, was der User da so tut anhand dessen, was da pro IP-Adresse, also pro Computer, der sich dann dieses Funknetzwerk eingeklingt hat, was da an Datenverkehr gemacht wird. Und der kann das aufsummieren und der kann einfach nette Grafen draus generieren und das dem Benutzer anzeigen. Und wenn du dir so eine Apple-Station kaufst, dann kannst du dir auch anschauen, wer da irgendwie gerade mit bei dir mit dem W-Lan ist und kannst dir irgendwie anzeigen lassen, wie viel Traffic der macht. Und von da einfach so per Knopfdruck steuerbar machen, so der war grad ein Böser oder vorher schon Limits festlegen. Das ist eigentlich keine Raketentechnologie, das sollte das eigentlich im Router, den du im Laden kaufen kannst, soll das einfach geben. Du solltest dir als Endbenutzer da keine Gedanken darüber machen, wie ich den jetzt zwischen ich hab schnelles und effizientes Netz und ich möchte meine Nachbarn trotzdem teilhaben lassen, wie man dazwischen abwägt, sondern da sollte einfach schon ein Feature sein, was in den Produkten aus dem Läden einfach mitkommt.
Aber warum baut das denn keiner, wenn es so einfach ist?
Schreifunk baut es gerade und wir könnten einfach mal, keine Ahnung, wir heißen den Router Linksys, anschreiben und sagen, mach doch mal bitte, es ist irgendwie ein geiles Feature und wir hätten das gerne und das würde uns auch dabei helfen, auch den Fangen den Leecher in der WG einfacher zu machen. Einfach mal rauszufinden, wer da gerade wieder den meisten Datenverkehr macht. Das ist ja auch in der WG ein typisches Problem.
Oder in gewissen Behausungen, wo mehrere Leute sind, die Internet nutzen und zwar gemeinsam. Falls ihr dazu gehört, dann ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt gekommen, auf Folgendes zu tun. Jetzt, hallo!
0331 70 97 110 Aber ich glaube ja langsam, was ihr erzählt, sind alles nur Geschichten.
Es gibt in Berlin und Brandenburg überhaupt niemand, der WLAN hat. Die Frage verschüttelt oder unverschüttelt stellt sich also anscheinend für euch nicht. Für uns ja aber schon. Es gab ja früher mal dieses eine Firma, die hat das sozusagen, das was Freifunk macht, quasi professionell gemacht. Fonero oder irgendwie so. Da konnte man ja sozusagen so ein Router kaufen und der hat dann automatisch ein Netz für mich zu Hause gemacht und ein Netz für die anderen draußen.
Gibt es überhaupt noch?
Ja, das gibt es noch. Die haben jetzt inzwischen auch so ein bisschen Probleme gekriegt, weil der Geschäftsmodell besteht darin, dass alle so ein Gerät aufstellen und das kaufen und dann läuft da diese Software von Fon drauf, die zwar auch Open Source ist, aber halt dann doch noch so ein bisschen was drin hat. Fast nach Hause telefoniert, das muss das auch haben und das spannt dann ein Netz für dich auf und ein öffentliches Netz. Und wenn du jetzt Fonero bist, dann kannst du halt überall, wo es eine Fonbox gibt, surfen. Wenn du kein Fonero bist, dann musst du dafür bezahlen. Und an diesem Bezahlen stören sich halt irgendwie Provider, weil da plötzlich was wiederverkauft wird und da gab es dann irgendwie Ärger. Und das ist in der nächsten Instanz. Und da wissen wir halt auch noch nicht, wie ich Fonos löse.
Juristisch ist es sozusagen so eine Sache. Wie sieht es so vom technischen Aspekt aus, sagt der Freifunk oder der ARR Besitzer, dass es so funktionieren könnte? Oder findet ihr das suspekt?
Wir wissen ja, wie es funktioniert, weil die brauchen ja auch Leute, die es implementieren. Und dann sind wieder die Open VR-Teller und die Freifunker dabei. Die müssen nämlich auch irgendwie arbeiten. Und technisch gesehen unterscheidet sich das Ding kaum von einem Freifunkrouter. Das Basissystem ist das gleiche. Die machen auch ganz schicke Hardware. Und das sind auch nur zwei Handgriffe, um aus einem Fonrouter einen Freifunkrouter zu machen.
Alles klar.
Apropos Freifunk, wir haben jetzt hier einen gewissen Keks am Apparat. Hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Und du bist auch ein Freifunker? Das frag ich doch einfach mal warum.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen aus Interesse entstanden bei mir. Damals irgendwie noch in einer Grundschule. Nee, nicht in einer Grundschule, in einer Oberschule so. Nee, und hat mich ein Kumpel angesprochen und meinte, ach guck mal hier, du interessierst dich ja auch für WLAN und sowas, aber was wir hier machen, wollen irgendwie unsere Stadt vernetzen. Und dann bin ich ein bisschen dazugekommen, ja, und hab die Community hier mit aufgebaut.
Irgendwie in Belgien, Norden.
Und jetzt durch diese neuen Entwicklungen, gibt dir das irgendwie zu denken oder ist es genau so Latte? Oder sagst du, nimmst du das Risiko einfach in Kauf?
Also wir danken uns ja schon ein bisschen drum. Also wir kriegen ja auch die Abmahnung ins Haus. Und ist nicht einfach für die Leute, war ich mal. Aber als Gemeinschaft hat man natürlich ein bisschen mehr Chancen. Man kann sich da irgendwie mal zusammentun und auch gemeinsam klagen. Das ist alles dann als Einzelperson ein bisschen schwieriger.
Also sagst du auch, okay, in der Gemeinschaft das geht. Was würdest du denn jetzt sagen, wenn ich so einen Kumpel jetzt frag, oder eine Freundin, du weißt genau, die hat irgendwie keinen Plan von Technik, wenn die dich jetzt um deine ehrliche Meinung fragt, soll ich meinen WLAN offen lassen oder soll ich es zumachen? Was sagst du ihr dann?
Tja, also wenn man es offen lässt, hat man wahrscheinlich ein paar Probleme mehr, als wenn man jetzt sagt, man bietet es direkt an und macht daraus vielleicht so etwas wie Freifunk. Und hat dann nicht so die Probleme, wie wenn man jetzt alleine da steht und jetzt irgendwie seinen Router aufmacht und keinen Plan mehr hat von allem, was da um einen rum passiert.
Das heißt, entweder ist man bei den Freifunkern oder du sagst, wenn man keinen Plan hat, dann lieber zumachen.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt ja auch so Sachen wie bei uns, dass man, wenn man sich einloggt, dann erstmal so eine Info-Seite kriegt. Ja, du bist jetzt hier gerade im Freifunk und du hast dich eigentlich ein bisschen nach den Grundregeln des Gemeinschaftsleben zu verhalten. Und da gehört einfach Feilschere nicht dazu. Und Sachen, die jetzt uns kaputt machen würden. Und das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht mal schlecht, dass man dann auch den Leuten nochmal klarmacht, du bist jetzt hier nicht für dich allein und du kannst hier nicht frei drehen, sondern bist schon irgendwo noch...
Dann bleibt es aber sozusagen wieder in der Gesellschaft steigend. Mal angenommen, ein bisschen spekuliert, irgendwie der BGH entscheidet demnächst so, also Freifunker, ihr seid auch verantwortlich, wenn über euer Netz da irgendwie Unsinn passiert. Würdest du dann damit aufhören? Oder gibt es eine Grenze, wo du sagst, jetzt wird es mir zu heiß? Oder findest du den Gedanken, Netz für alle so prickelnd, dass du sagst, ich bleibe auf jeden Fall dabei?
Na ja, ist ja auch eine Frage, ist es nur Internet, was man macht? Oder ist es ein Netzwerk, was man hat? Und also für jeden Einzelnen, ich meine, nicht jeder, der Freifunk macht, sage ich mal, hat auch nicht, hat Internet zu Hause oder gibt es frei? Es ist ja jedem selbst überlassen, wie weit er das macht. Und gerade jetzt hier sind wir auch dabei, Sachen zu entwickeln. Ich weiß nicht, ob da schon was zugesagt wurde, dass wir den Leuten noch ein bisschen mehr Verantwortung geben, dass sie dann halt ihre eigenen IP-Adressen kriegen und die da für ein Stück weit verantwortlich sind für das, was sie da tun.
Das heißt sozusagen, jeder, der über Freifunk schafft, ist dann eindeutig identifizierbar?
Nicht unbedingt eindeutig identifizierbar. Man hat seinen festen Punkt, wo das endet, aber wer dahintersteckt, das wissen wir ja auch selber nicht so richtig. Aber wir können die Benutzer zuordnen. Sie haben sich einmal diese IP-Adresse genommen und benutzen sie und sie müssen sich auch irgendwann mal... Also sie können das nicht mehrmals neben uns einfach rausgreifen. Also schon so ein bisschen was, wo man die Leute zuordnen könnte, aber wir wissen nicht hundertprozentig, ob der Mensch dahinter steckt, wie draußen am Telefonfeld zu telefonieren. Da wird ja auch keiner auf die Ideen kommen und da Kameras hinhängen, obwohl man ja... Jetzt ja schon hab ich...
Oder vielleicht doch, man weiß es nicht so genau.
Naja, hier so mit Touchscreen und so, ja.
Skin Display.
Okay, das ist glaube ich dann ein anderes Chaosradio mit Kameras und den Scan-Displays und den Fingerabdruckscannern. Du wirst auf jeden Fall weiter beim Freifunk bleiben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Kann man dich auch irgendwie fragen, wenn man Fragen zum Freifunk hat? So als Nicht-Auskenner?
Also ich glaube, da ist jeder, der ein bisschen was davon weiß, allen gesünder was zu erzählen. Also ich meine, es ist sehr familiär, sagen wir mal, dass man sich da auch, ich weiß nicht, bei uns ist es so, wir treffen uns einmal in der Woche in einer Kneipe, zum Stammtisch, da haben wir eigentlich...
Wann denn, wo denn? Also jetzt genau, es geht ja darum zu zeigen, dass die Freifunk jetzt nicht nur eine große Gruppe ist, sondern dass du jetzt ganz konkret Teil einer kleineren Freifunker Gruppe gibst, die sich jeden Montag oder jeden ersten Frühjahrs...
Jeden Donnerstag sind wir dabei.
Jeder Donnerstag wo?
Im Weißen See, im Herbertz, das ist so eine kleine Kneipe da in der BSEE-Straße, glaube ich.
Okay, wenn man mal sagen, irgendwie wissen wir Freifunk, was ist das eigentlich, wie sehen die Leute aus, die das machen? Geht man einfach dahin?
Genau, geht man hin, fragt die Leute und ich weiß nicht, also in Berlin gibt es dann auch nochmal ein überregionales Treffen für alle. Mittwochs irgendwie, deswegen ruft heute wahrscheinlich die Utgener an. Die sitzen alle schön im Hacker-Space in Mitte und trinken da gemeinsam Mate und schlägen große Pläne für Berlin.
Na toll, das habt ihr ja gut getimet.
Tut mir leid.
Irgendwas ist immer. Aber Keks, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und frohes Freifunk noch.
Alles klar, bis denn, tschüss.
So, wenn ihr da auch mitmacht oder wenn ihr denkt, Gott, Freifunk mal wieder aufmachen, niemals würde ich das tun, dann könnt ihr hier anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und Erdgeist, kannst du auch schon sagen nochmal?
Keine Ahnung.
Na toll.
Du musst schon anfangen.
Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110 Jetzt kommen wir zu einer Frage, die natürlich sozusagen spannend ist für alle Leute, die sich von den W-Lan irgendwie fragen, wie geht denn das überhaupt? Dafür haben wir den Paul am Telefon. Was war deine Frage?
Also, ihr habt ja schon angesprochen, dass jemand auf der Straße einfach irgendwie den Netzarzt durch diese Schlüssel sich hacken kann oder so und dann in mein Internet, also in meinen W-Lan, sein kann und sich irgendwelche Illegalen, also irgendwas Illegales machen kann bei mir. Wieviel vor kriegt er erstens die Netzarztstücke? Und wieviel vor kriegt er erst mal her?
Also, da gibt es zwei Punkte, worüber wir sprechen, dass es überhaupt keine Sicherheitseinstellung für das W-Lan erst gab. Dass man einfach gesagt hat, ist es offen. Aber ganz früher wurden die ersten Netzwerke mit einem Verschlüsselungsstandard namens WEP gesichert. Und dieser Standard ist aus kryptographisch-mathematischer Sicht eigentlich ziemlich einfach knackbar gewesen. Und heute gibt es irgendwie schon Programme, mit denen kann man so ein paar Pakete mitlesen. Dann lässt man den Computer so eine Stunde rechnen und danach hat man den Schlüssel ausgerechnet und kann sich dann an diesem Netzwerk genauso bewegen. Also die alten Verschlüsselungsstandards, wenn man es ernst meint, wie WEP, sollte man einfach geflüssentlich gleich überspringen und WPA oder WPA2 benutzen. Man kann die Schlüssel ausrechnen lassen, wenn man es darauf will.
Also sagen, jetzt eine genaue Anleitung zu geben, das wird ein bisschen lang dauern, aber sozusagen um es mal zu sagen, wie es funktionieren kann. Man setzt ja beim Rechner hin, klappt das auf, liest eine Weile mit, lässt den Rechner dann ein bisschen rechnen. Also zumindest beim WEP und hat dann sozusagen genau den Schlüssel, wie das WLAN verschlüsselt ist und kann dann schön mitlesen. Das ist also relativ einfach, wenn man diese kleine Verschlüsselung nimmt. Ich hoffe, das beantwortet die Frage.
Ja, und wie funktioniert das eigentlich nochmal mit dem Freifunk? Also da hat einer irgendwo diesen Freifunk und die anderen Leute können halt ohne irgendwelche Schlüsselungen oder sowas mit dem Internet gehen und von Nachbarn zu Nachbarn weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Bis irgendwann halt die halbe Stadt mit versorgt ist. Also halb Berlin, wenn man mit Freifunk versorgt ist.
Die Antwort auf diese Frage ist, der Kurz genau so ist es. Oder habe ich da was falsch verstanden?
Wenn du wissen willst, wo man dann ins Internet kommt, es gibt halt ein paar Leute, die ihre DSL-Anschlüsse zur Verfügung stellen. Entweder ihren ganzen DSL-Anschluss oder sie stellen ein, lassen sie nur die Hälfte freigeben. Und dann gibt es in Berlin irgendwie so 20, 30 Internetanschlüsse verteilt über die Stadtteile und du suchst dir automatisch den nächstgelegenen Internetanschluss, damit du über möglichst wenig hops. So heißt das nämlich, wenn man von einem Router zum nächsten hoppt, zum Internet kommt. Das macht das darunter liegende Routing-Protokoll dann automatisch. Zumindest wenn es funktioniert.
Also um nochmal jede Verfügung zu vermeiden. Es gibt also Leute, die haben Internetanschlüsse, die stellen diese zur Verfügung. Und dann gibt es sozusagen eine ganze Batterie von Routern, die dieses Internet, was diese wenigen Leute breitstellen, über der Stadt verteilen. Alright, hätten wir das geklärt. Paul, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf. Und viel Spaß beim Freifunk. Wir haben auch schon ein paar mal erklärt, wo man hingehen muss, wenn man damit anfangen will.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio und es geht um die Frage, ob euer W-Lan offen oder zu ist. Das Internet ist schon wieder voll.
Und das war...
Im IRC, also im Chat zu dieser Sendung, wird es nicht mehr beschwert, wenn Musik gespielt wird. Es sei doch ein Talkradio, aber Leute, wir müssen beim Chaosradio auch mal Luft holen. Außerdem ist es auch Musik, die quasi mit dem Thema zu tun hat, das ist nämlich Creative Commons Musik. Heißt, kann man einfach runterladen und weitergeben, ohne dass irgendein Rechtsanwalt ankommt und sagt, nein, Abmahnung. In diesem speziellen Fall war es sogar quasi zwei Creative Commons Musiken in einem. Das waren nämlich Zoe Lila und Remix von Professor Klick. Zwei sehr bekannte Creative Commons Musiker, sehr zu empfehlen. Link gibt's im Wiki zur Sendung, genau wie ihr den Weg zum Chat finden könnt. Alles unter chaosradio.de. Viel Spaß dort. Wir sprechen heute über W-Lan und die Frage, macht man das auf? Lässt man das zu? Weil möglicherweise ist man verantwortlich für Unfug, der darüber passiert. Bei mir zu Gast ist Erbgeist vom Chaos Computer Club. Und Alex von den Freifunkern. Und immer auch ihr, wenn ihr wollt. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Denn es gibt anscheinend doch ein paar Fragen, die sie dir aufgetan haben, bei euch da draußen, zum Beispiel bei Amelie.
Namen zusammen. Und zwar, jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit über W-Lans gesprochen, aber ich hab mal eine Anwenderfrage. Und zwar, wenn ich mich jetzt entscheide, über ein Freifunknetz zu surfen, haben wir ja gerade schon gehört, dass dann der Betreibungsnetzwerk quasi auch mitsniffen kann. Und ja, ich wollte halt mal fragen, ob es irgendwelche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die man vielleicht, oder Plugins, die man installieren kann, die man benutzen kann, um da so ein bisschen mehr, ja, Anonymität zu bekommen. Also, dass man Online-Banking nicht über solche Netze macht, ist mir auch klar, aber...
Warum nicht? Also dein Online-Banking würdest du doch im Allgemeinen genau über eine Adresse tun, die du in deinem Browser eingibst und darauf wartest, bis deine Titelleiste grün wird. Und dann solltest du vielleicht noch dein Zertifikat nachgucken, aber das solltest du eigentlich bei dir zu Hause auch tun. Warum vertraust du denn deinem Anbieter deines Internetses mehr als dem Anbieter des Freifunknetzes?
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Frage, bei der ich noch nicht nachgedacht habe. Ja, okay, so kann man es natürlich auch sehen. Ja, ich hab dann ja eigentlich eher so das Bild im Kopf, dass da jetzt irgendwo irgendein Mensch rum sitzt, der jetzt gerade den kompletten Netzwerkverkehr, also es muss jetzt noch nicht mal ein Freifunknetz sein, explizit. Also ich meine, so im Allgemeinen auf eine Netze bezogen.
Das ist doch aber im Allgemeinen eher der Staat, der mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorhat, dort genau den Datenverkehr anzugucken und nicht der böse Hacker. Also das ist irgendwie so ein Bild, was mir irgendwie Angst macht, dass Leute da draußen glauben im Internet, würden wirklich nur böse Leute unterwegs sein und die würden dir einfach nur nach deinem Rechner trachten. Okay, aber du hast natürlich schon recht, du solltest immer schauen, dass egal, wo du gerade ins Netz gehst, sei es bei dir zu Hause, sei es irgendwo in einem Café oder sei es bei einem Betreiber eines offenen W-Lans, kann der natürlich sämtlichen unverschlüsselten Datenverkehr nicht nur mitlesen, sondern auch manipulieren. Also wenn du Spiegel.de oder deine Lieblingsnachrichtenseite irgendwo in einem Internetcafé dir anguckst, dann kann es sein, dass da irgendjemand Schabernack treibt und da einfach lustige Artikel reintut, um dich zu ärgern. Klar, aber du musst dir immer bewusst sein, wo du gerade deine Daten herholst und wie diese Daten gesichert sind, dass die wirklich von der Quelle kommen, von der du glaubst.
Na gut, aber wenn ich jetzt ein eigenes Leben habe, dann bin ich mir sicher, es ist dann immer an meiner Möglichkeit, dass wirklich ich auf diese Daten zugreife. Aber wenn ich jetzt in ein offenes Netz reingehe, naja, weiß ich ja nicht, wer das noch so mitbekommt.
Na ja, es ist so, dass es Spiegel.de und ähnliche Webseiten gibt, da tut das niemandem weh, wenn da mitgelesen wird. Und dann gibt es Webseiten, da möchtest du, dass das keiner mitliest. Und bei diesen Webseiten achtest du darauf, dass vorne oben in dieser Browserleiste HTTPS steht und S steht für Secure. Und das bedeutet, dass die Verschlüsselung zwischen deinem Computer, genau genommen zwischen deinem Browser und dem Server des Anbieters stattfindet. Und wenn der Anbieter kein HTTPS anbietet, dann spart er zwar eine ganze Menge Geld, aber er spart es auf deine Kosten. Und dann musst du dir wirklich überlegen, ob das ein seriöser Anbieter ist, der dir halt, wenn du mit persönlichen Daten handierst, diese Verschlüsselung gibt, weil das kostet dem Anbieter natürlich auch, oder nicht. Und wenn der das nicht anbietet, dann solltest du vielleicht einfach den Anbieter wechseln.
Na gut, ich meinte jetzt aber eigentlich eher, ob es noch irgendwelche anderen Alternativen, also es gibt zum Beispiel Tor oder so weiter, ob es da jetzt irgendwelche, ja, noch Sachen gibt, die ihr noch empfehlen könnt. Also darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinausreißen.
Entschuldige, ich glaube, wir müssen uns da nochmal entschuldigen. Du kommst immer mit Tor und wir wollen dir HTTPS erklären, ich glaube.
Das HTTPS weiß ich auch, aber... Ich meine jetzt, klar HTTPS ist gut, das könnt ihr nochmal erklären, aber das ist mir durchaus ein Begriff. Ich meine jetzt eigentlich nur, ob ihr persönlich noch irgendwelche Empfehlungen habt, was man da vielleicht noch machen kann.
Natürlich ist es immer eine gute Idee, auch bei sich zu Hause Tor zu benutzen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du in einer WG wohnst oder...
Ja, in einer WG, richtig.
In einer WG und auch da sind sämtliche anderen Rechner deiner Mitbewohner, die in demselben WLAN sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Verhältnis von dir zu deinen Mitbewohnern noch ist.
Ja, noch ist es ganz gut, aber unser WLAN ist eh so...
Unser WLAN ist eh so zeuteoffen. Also wir leben in einem relativ großen Mietshaus und ich hab halt unten das Passwort unseres WLANs aufgehangen, weil ich mich nicht traue, meinen WLAN komplett offen zu machen. Aber jetzt können zumindest alle Hausbewohner da irgendwie mitsurfen.
Also ich hab mir irgendwie bei RelaxVPN, so ein VPN mal geklickt, das kostet dann irgendwie fünf Euro im Monat. Das ist glaube ich der Reseller, der das Pirate Bay VPN auch macht. Und da gibt es relativ viele Anbieter. Und es ist sogar ziemlich simpel, da kann man sich so einen VPN klicken. Und das kann man dann sogar mit einem normalen Linux-Windows-MAC irgendwie in drei Schritten einrichten. Das gibt es sogar auf meinem iPhone. Und dann wird der Traffic von deinem Gerät bis zum VPN-Gateway verschlüsselt. Und der VPN-Gateway-Betreiber kann mitlesen. Also diese Idee, dass keiner mitlesen kann.
Im Chat hat gerade jemand Angst, dass Tor mit Verschlüsseln verwechselt wird. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht der Fall. Das ist ja natürlich auch beim VPN. Wir reden jetzt gerade generell nur über die Möglichkeit, wie kannst du dich innerhalb eines bestimmten Netzwerkes, also in einem WLAN-Café oder bei dir zu Hause im WLAN oder in einem offenen WLAN bewegen, ohne dass die Leute, die auch in diesem WLAN unterwegs sind, irgendwie mitlesen können, was du da machst. Da verschlüsselt Tor ja schon, genau wie ein VPN.
Darf ich nur kurz fragen, was hast du dir für ein Passwort ausgesucht? Ist das irgendwie so eine Zahlenkolonne oder ist das ein leicht merkbares Wort?
Leicht merkbar geht anders. Das ist relativ lang, eigentlich. Aber ich kann es ja gleich ändern. Momentan ist es irgendwie Jesus was a crossmaker 127.0.0.1. Okay, cool.
Okay, das änderst du jetzt sozusagen?
Das ändere ich jetzt gerade in diesem Moment.
Ja, also ich finde, das sind coole Fragen, die Amelie gerade gestellt hat. Was sie immer noch nicht beantwortet hat, ist sozusagen, also doch, Alex hat es gemacht. Er hat gesagt, er eine RelaxVPN.
Ich sage irgendwie, Tor ist eine total gute Idee. Betreibst du auch einen Tor Exit Note bei dir zu Hause?
Nein, noch nicht.
Ich habe es noch nicht eingekriegt. Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen reingelesen.
Also Tor Exit Note ist jetzt auch gleich das ganz große Ding. Da gibt es dann gleich wieder juristische Ärger.
Genau, wollte ich ja noch mal.
Du hast damit angefangen, Helga, jetzt erklärst du, warum ein Tor Exit Note zu Hause möglicherweise unter Umständen problematisch sein kann.
Ein Tor Exit Note ist genau in diesem Verschleierungsnetzwerk, das Tor ja darstellt, wo du die Spuren verwischen kannst, indem du über mehrere Schritte deine Pakete erst durchs verschwüsselte Internet schickst, bevor es dann irgendwo auf der Welt und vielleicht auch bei jemandem zu Hause da kommen die Pakete wieder raus und dann erscheinen sie so, als ob sie bei denjenigen zu Hause einfach ins Internet geschubst worden wären. Und wenn da irgendjemand sich da jetzt im Internet zu schaffen macht, irgendwas Illegales tut, dann ist genau wie in so einem offenen W-Land der letzte Punkt, der identifizierbar ist, der Betreiber des Tor Exit Notes. Und da da nicht mal mehr eine räumliche Korrelation besteht, das heißt bei so einem W-Land muss man ja in die Nähe gefahren sein, bei so einem Tor Exit Note kann der irgendwo in der Welt sitzen. Und meistens gibt es dann den Ärger, weil die Leute sich dann daneben benehmen in diesen Tor-Netzwerken. Und deswegen sollte man sich sehr bewusst sein, ob man so einen Tor Exit Note betreibt und ob man diesen juristischen potenziellen Ärger dort auf sich nehmen möchte.
Man kann aber, um das noch zu Ende zu führen, auch einen Tor-Middelnote betreiben, also einer der sozusagen nur zwischen verschiedenen Tor-Rechnern vermittelt. Das ist dann nicht ganz so gefährlich, weil da eigentlich keiner weiß, wo was und überhaupt passiert. So, noch Fragen?
Nee, das ist was dann. Dankeschön.
Hey, na vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Bis später, tschüss.
Sehr schön. Seht ihr, das tut überhaupt gar nicht weh und möglicherweise könnt ihr die wieder anwesenden Gäste noch irgendwie in die Irre führen, weil sie glauben, ihr wisst viel weniger als ihr. Aber selbst wenn ihr überhaupt nichts wisst, könnt ihr auch anrufen und fragen, weil ehrlich, das ist das Anliegen der Leute, die hier sind, sozusagen zu informieren, wer auch immer was darüber wissen will. Zum Beispiel den Basti. Hallo Basti. Nein. Da hast du ein Problem?
Ne, jetzt nicht direkt, aber ich hab da auch schon eine Weile drüber nachgedacht, wie das ist. Also ich bin halt auch hier sozusagen derjenige, der den Kopf hinhält für unseren Internetanschluss, ja in der WG und unsere Nachbarn hängen da auch manchmal noch mit drin, ja. Und ihr habt ja schon gesagt, also Traffic mitlesen ist nicht, habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Aber irgendwo bin ich ja trotzdem sozusagen der, bei dem es landet, wenn da irgend einer File Sharing betreibt oder sonst was, was kann ich denn da machen, um mich da zu schützen irgendwie. Also ich wollte den Leuten jetzt das ja auch nicht mit irgendeinem Vertragswerk da winken, irgendwie hier unterschreiben, ich werde nicht bei Rapid Share und Amen. Was kann ich denn da machen?
Na ich denke, wenn du die Leute kennst, wenn die bei dir in einer WG wohnen, dann geh da irgendwie hin und sag irgendwie, ich halte da meinen Kopf hin und möchte nicht, dass ich da auf die Finger bekomme. Und wenn ihr irgendwie Ärger macht, dann müsst ihr das auch ausstehen und das ist zumindest das einzige, was du dann wie sozial machen kannst ansonsten.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja sowieso klar, aber halt so ganz drin stecken tut man ja auch nicht. Oder wenn einer neu einzieht und so, prinzipiell kann ich mich da eigentlich wenig gegenschützen dann im Endeffekt, dass dann irgendwann der Kelch doch bei mir landet. Also sollte irgendwas sein, oder?
Ich verstehe gerade nicht. Du wohnst mit diesen Leuten in einer Wohnung zusammen, aber du würdest dann am Ende nicht mit denen einfach das W-Lan auf dieselbe Art und Weise teilen wollen? Also da gibt es ein grundsätzliches Vertrauensproblem?
Nee, nee, nee, um Gottes Willen gar nicht. Mir geht es mehr um die grundsätzliche Frage eigentlich, ob man da...
Die stell ich doch gerade. Ich meine, du teilst mit denen irgendwie das Intimste, wie du lebst mit denen irgendwie zusammen auf engstem Raum, aber beim W-Lan hört denn die Freundschaft auf, oder?
Nee, nee, so hab ich das gar nicht gemeint. Ich hab da überhaupt nicht vor, irgendwie da jetzt irgendwelche Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Die Leute hier sind das Vollste vertrauen, aber ich frag dich halt einfach grundsätzlich, wie ist denn das? Angenommen, ich hätte jetzt jemanden, der da irgendwie Scheiße baut, dann könnte ich das überhaupt irgendwie, wenn ich dann hier Post vom Anwalt kriege, könnte ich das überhaupt irgendwie an den weiterleiten? Oder bin ich dann...
Du kannst das wahrscheinlich nicht nachweisen auf die Art und Weise, die da gerichtsfest wäre, weil du am Ende derjenige bist, der als letztes identifizierbar ist, aber du kannst natürlich dein Mitbewohner dann so lange mit einem Löffel verprügeln, bis er wieder hängt und sagt, ja, ich war's.
Weil der Löffel stumpf ist.
Also wir halten fest, wenn ihr in euer WG ein Wlan einrichtet, ja dann solltet ihr einen Löffel in der Wohnung haben. Also mal ehrlich sozusagen. Erstens, Warnung, wer Erdges eine Frage stellt, bekommt möglicherweise eine philosophisch-soziale Antwort oder Gegenfrage. Zweitens, man kann das nicht wirklich klären. Also sozusagen, wenn du jetzt wirklich nach dem rein juristischen fragst, ist der Anschlussinhaber der, wo es im Moment endet? Weil es gibt einfach keine Möglichkeiten, dass der das irgendwie weitergibt, die Verantwortung. Alex, du wolltest noch was?
Teilt ihr euch denn auch das Telefon? Und jeder kann das einfach so benutzen, ohne seinen Ausweis abzugeben?
Nee, das ist keine Verarschung. Das ist irgendwie so wirklich generell ein Problem, dass mit dem Internet irgendwie viel mehr gerade assoziiert wird, dass irgendwie viel mehr Ärger passiert. Aber in der Zeit, wo irgendwie 0- und 900-Nummern dir finanziellen Ärger galoreinbringen können, ist, glaube ich, irgendwie W-Land doch das geringere Risiko. Oder dass irgendjemand auf deinen Namen zu dir nach Hause, der auch unter einer WG wohnt, dass er dir irgendwie Waren nach Hause schicken lässt, irgendwie so...
Ich möchte aber mal jetzt...
Ich kann ja auch jemanden, der mich überhaupt nicht kennt, der braucht ja nur meine Adresse irgendwo und dann bestellt er auf meinen Namen.
Ich möchte jetzt mal, die Telefonlage spinnt gerade, sagst du deinen Namen bitte nochmal? Basti, ich möchte Basti mal ein bisschen Schutz nehmen. Ich glaube, es kommt daher, weißt du, wenn ich irgendwie, wenn ich dein Telefon nehme und einen 100er nochmal anrufe, dann kostet dich vielleicht irgendwie 120 oder 500 Euro. Wenn du eine Repost noch von Abmannanwalt bekommst, dann sind es halt irgendwie möglicherweise 4-5-stellige Ziffern. Ich glaube, daher kommt diese Angst. Ich würde sagen, einfach um die Frage zu beantworten, man könnte vielleicht sagen, weil du deinen Leuten in der Wohnung nicht vertraust. Genau, aber das ist tatsächlich auch die Antwort auf die Frage, die du gestellt hast, ja? Also du solltest WLAN nicht mit Leuten teilen, denen du nicht vertraust, weil genau das kann dann passieren. Es gibt also sagen auf die Frage, wie kann ich mich den Schutzmöglichkeiten weitergeben, gibt es keine zufriedenstellende Antwort?
Ja, also falls euch beruhigt, ich werde jetzt morgen hier meinen Mitbewohner nicht den WLAN-Schlüssel entziehen.
Aber die vom Chaosradio haben gesagt, Leecher, mach dir die Löffel bereit und dann.
Kein Internet mehr für euch.
Aber deine Frage ist trotzdem beantwortet. Es gibt keine Antwort quasi.
Alright, ja sorry, bis dann, tschüss.
So, ja wie gesagt, normalerweise haben wir so eine total geile Anlage, wo man so reinschreiben kann, ja, wir rufen uns an, was will denn ihr überhaupt, das funktioniert heute nicht, deswegen telefonieren wir jetzt mit.
Ja, du bist es, wer bist du?
Du hast gewonnen.
Ja, ich fände übrigens das kleine Zitat, was gefallen ist, teile deinen WLAN nicht mit Leuten, denen du nicht vertraust. Das passt ganz gut zu dem, was ich vorhin der liebreizenden Dame am Telefon auch gesagt habe. Und zwar möchte ich nämlich darauf einsteigen, die technischen Gründe oder Hintergründe haben wir ganz gut, oder habt ihr ganz gut geklärt, finde ich. Da ist vieles gesagt worden. Ich hatte auch noch mal was zu verschlüsselten und unverschlüsselten Verbindungen, aber da sage ich vielleicht nachher noch mal einen kleinen Schlag zu. Mich interessiert eigentlich eher, wenn ich jetzt im Prinzip wirklich meinen WLAN nicht teilen soll mit Leuten, denen ich nicht vertraue, dann kann ich ja so mehr oder weniger zum Beispiel diese Freifunkgeschichte auch nicht betreiben. Oder doch? Also da vielleicht mal...
Also ich versuche jetzt mal die Leinantwort zu geben, als jemand, der sich sozusagen nicht so derbe doll auskennt. Wenn du dein WLAN nicht teilen willst, dann ist es nur für dich da, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten. Experten?
Sollte so sein. Also das, was du heute zu kaufen bekommst, ist glaube ich schon mit keiner Kindergarten-Kryptographie mehr gesichert. Da kannst du schon davon ausgehen.
Ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus. Es geht jetzt mal nicht speziell um mich, sondern halt eher generell darauf. Oder darum... Meine These ist ja, wenn ich jetzt halt das alles verfolge, wo sich die Gerichte entscheiden, sozusagen wie die Gesetze sich ändert und reagiert auf die Begebenheiten, dann habe ich da ehrlich gesagt, ich bin auch einer, der sagt, genau wie ihr das vorhin auch schön ausgeführt habt, wenn jemand Unfug treibt in deinem Netzwerk, mit dem ich das erlaubt habe, dann spreche ich halt mit dem. Ganz klar, das ist eine gute Idee. Sollte man machen, bevor man den Anwalt auf den Hals setzt. Und ich finde auch ganz gut, dass solche Netzwerke gibt, die frei sind oder die freinutzbar sind. Natürlich möchte ich alsjenige, der das erste zur Verfügung stellt, sicher sein, dass ich nicht total den Hammer kriege, wenn jemand anderes doch Unfug treiben sollte. Auch wenn ich dem erst mal potenziell vertraue. Andererseits kann ich dem ja auch nicht sofort den Riegel vorschieben. Also ich kann ja nicht alle Ports zumachen, könnte ich. Aber ist ja dann auch irgendwie nicht mehr schön. So, die Frage ist jetzt halt, bewegen wir uns mit diesen ganzen freien Netzwerken eventuell auch auf die Richtung zu? Einfach notgedrungen, weil die Gesetzeslage uns immer mehr zumacht. So wie das jetzt die offiziellen Provider oder die großen Provider, die kommerziellen auch schon tun. Das heißt eigentlich ist es ja so, Freifunk reagiert jetzt mit dieser heuristischen Geschichte so ein bisschen und macht dann im Zweifelsfall die Ports zu. Jetzt kommt da so die Idee auf, auch mal ein bisschen personalisiert daran zu gehen oder zumindest halt zu sagen, wenn jemand uns...
Ich verliere langsam den Faden. Was ist deine Frage?
Meine Frage ist, werden die Netzwerke wie Freifunk, die jetzt noch im Prinzip eine Alternative bieten, in fünf Jahren einfach durch die Gesetzeslage auch dazu gezwungen sein, ihren Service aufzugeben bzw. so stark personenbezogen nachvollziehbar zu sein, dass es sich auch nicht mehr lohnt mit der Ausnahme, dass es kostenfrei ist?
Okay. Also ich möchte jetzt irgendwie, um das ein bisschen abzukutzen, weil wir haben schon viel drüber gesprochen. Der aktuelle Stand ist, wir können es nicht sagen, wir müssen abwarten, was noch passiert. Wer das nochmal nachverfolgen will, dem empfehle ich den Podcast dieser Sendung. Der erscheint im Laufe der Nacht noch auf fritz.de und später dann noch auf chaosradio.de. Aber wir können ja mal in die Kristallkugel gucken.
Hier haben wir eine Kristallkugel. Also das Ding ist, es gibt immer einen Plan B und einen Plan C und einen Plan D. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wo man ist. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Konzepte. Wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt diese Heuristiken. Wir haben den Peer-to-Peer-Blocker. Wir können die Leute runtershäppen. Das ist State of the Art. Dann gibt es eine ganze Menge Leute, die gerade anfangen zu sagen, lasst uns doch mal irgendwie gemeinsam so einen Server in der Tschechei oder ganz aktuell auch Island irgendwie mieten und unseren Traffic darüber leiten. Weil in dem Moment, wo Traffic grenzüberschreitend ist und Abmahnungen grenzüberschreitend sind, kriegen die Anwälte irgendwie ein großes P in den Augen und sagen, hach, das ist ja viel zu viel Arbeit für das bisschen Geld, das wir da holen können. Dann machen wir sowieso nicht mit. Dann sind wir in Berlin dabei, irgendwie öffentliche IP-Adressen zu verteilen. Dann ist das plötzlich deine Adresse wieder und nicht mehr die von jemand anderem. Der Keks hat es ja schon erwähnt. Und dann steht an der Adresse halt eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und wenn die sagen, hach ja, über diese Adresse sind ganz böse Dinge passiert, dann sagen wir ja, die ist registriert auf folgende E-Mail-Adresse, musst du klarkommen, wie du damit klarkommst. Mehr Daten haben wir über den Besundbenutzer nicht. Und das leiten wir dann über große BGB-Gateways ins Internet und aus dem Internet auch wieder ins Freifunknetz. Dafür haben wir dann so hübsche Richtstrecken, die sich zwischen irgendwelchen Kirchen und Unis und anderen hohen Gebäuden in der Stadt verteilen und diese Daten dann von den Provalern, wo der Übergabepunkt ist, in die Stadt leiten. Da haben wir den Ring um Berlin schon fast drei Viertel fertig. Ich übertreibe jetzt maßlos. Und dann ist es ja auch noch so, und da muss man ja sehen, fünf Jahre ist eine lange Zeit. Die Politik hat jetzt das Internet entdeckt und die Piraten treiben sie alle vor sich her. Die Grünen fangen jetzt an, irgendwie das Freifunk zu entdecken und alle wollen Netzpolitik machen. Und das heißt, ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass die Entwicklung linear weitergeht. Weil mit Freifunk und mit diesen ganzen Geschichten kann man unheimlich viel Wählerstimmen und Sympathiepunkte reinholen. Und das, was die Grünen und die Piraten da machen, irgendwie das schreibt die SPD und die Link und die CDU ab, und die FDP sowieso. Und plötzlich wollen alle das Gleiche. Und dann lässt sich das relativ schnell umsetzen, weil es da überhaupt keine mehr Fragen gibt. Also ich denke, dass wir da noch interessante Zeiten vor uns haben.
Genau, das ist nämlich nicht nur eine juristische, sondern auch eine politische Frage. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass dort auch wenn es politisch gewollt ist, wenn begriffen wurde, dass das Internet in Deutschland einfach so in der Informationsgesellschaft so ein sehr kostbares Gut ist, dann wird man es einfach nicht so maßlos einfach kaputt spielen. Aber ich denke, dass man auch vielleicht vorausschauend sagen kann, wenn man es irgendwie nicht als Gefahr deklariert, der man sich da aussetzt mit einem offenen W-Land, sondern einfach als Risiko kann man vielleicht sogar dahergehen und eine Versicherung drauf abschließen. Du hast mit deiner Hausratsversicherung einfach so eine Tagchen noch dran. Ich versichere mich gegen Internetvandalismus-Schäden, wenn jemand aus meinem W-Land irgendwas tut. Und es gibt ja auch Schwarzfahrerversicherungen in Frankreich ganz erfolgreich. Und man kann da einfach mal gegen so tollwütige Anwälte dort auch einfach mal Vorsorge treffen. Also vielleicht ist das dann irgendwie auch innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre noch ein Weg.
Also Patrick, ich hoffe, wir können deine Bedenken so ein bisschen zerstreuen. Es wird also nicht so sein, dass das Freifunk demnächst baden geht, sondern es ist eher wahrscheinlich, dass es entweder einen Plan B gibt oder halt sozusagen sogar politische Alternative, um wir demnächst über das CDU-Freifunknet surfen können.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall alles sehr gut. Ja, ich hoffe nur halt, dass sozusagen die Leute, die so eine Netzwerke anbieten oder ihren Hut raufen lassen, irgendwie nicht sich selber dazu treiben, halt auch so eine Art Vorratsdatenspeicher privat betreiben zu wollen oder zu müssen.
Also ich glaube, ich versteige mich jetzt nicht, wenn ich sage, dass Leute, die Freifunk betreiben, generell auch Leute, sind die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht so prall für die.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind dabei, den TCP-Dump um eine Anonymisierungsfunktion zu erweitern.
Dass die aus dem Netzwerk mitgeschnittenen Pakete so weit anonymisiert oder pseudonymisiert werden, dass sie keiner einzelnen Person mehr zuzuordnen sind.
Und was die Politik betrifft, ist letzte Woche in der Bezirksverordnetenversammlung Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf der Antrag Freifunk für alle über die Konsensliste in den Baurausschuss verwiesen worden und wird dort im Laufe der nächsten Monate verhandelt. Das heißt, die Politik ist da tatsächlich dran und das ist nicht nur ein Hirngespinz. Da passiert eine ganze Menge.
Und vielleicht sehen wir uns im Freifunk.
Bis dann, tschüss.
So, dann geht ja ganz munter hier weiter. Brennt euch jetzt gerade noch was auf der Seele oder machen wir weiter mit den Anrufern?
Das funktioniert richtig gut in Brandenburg, weil die Leute sagen, okay, ich sitze hier auf dem Derben und ich habe hier kein Internet. Aber wir haben hier ein fettes Getreidesilo und irgendwie 15 Kilometer weiter ist ein fetter Kirchturm und DSL-Anschluss und dann bauen die nämlich einfach eine Funkstrecke über 15 Kilometer oder über 10 Kilometer. Das ist inzwischen unter 300 Euro zu realisieren. Verteilen das Ganze einfach mit ein bisschen Freifunktechnik im Dorf und so gibt es vier, fünf, sechs Dörfer in Brandenburg, Ostdeutschland, die völlig unabhängig von der Telekom sind. Die haben Internet, die haben inzwischen einen gemieteten DSL-Anschluss, der auch nicht mehr von der Telekom kommt, 15 Kilometer weiter und die Dorf versorgt sich selbst. Das sind dann 70, 80, 100 Freifunknoten und alle sind glücklich und haben festgestellt, hey, geil, Informationsgesellschaft kann man selber bauen, dafür braucht man gar keine Großunternehmen mehr.
Das ist ja cool, höre ich zum ersten Mal vor. Großartig. Wenn da jetzt jemand gerade zuhört, naja vermute ich, sie sind zu beschäftigt mit Netzstrohhälmen, wenn jetzt jemand zuhört, bitte ruft an und erzählt von dem Projekt. Das fände ich richtig spannend, 0331 70 97 110 ist immer noch die Telefonnummer. Und hier haben wir noch einen weiteren Anrufer, dessen Namen ich nicht weiß, weil die Telefonanlage uns heute nicht mag. Guten Abend.
Hey, wer bist denn du? Du bist Stefan.
Du hast eine Frage oder eine Meinung?
Kurze Schilderung, ja, Meinung. Also eine Frage habe ich aktuell nicht. Also ich habe hier, wie wahrscheinlich so viele andere Leute auch, halt einen W-Lan zu Hause und das eben auch zum Nachbarn erweitert. Aktuell ist es verschlüsselt. Ist hier auch so ein bisschen open derpen. Also Modell Brandenburg möchte ich sagen. Freifunk würde sich hier sicherlich nicht lohnen. Ich meine, du kannst zwar irgendwo deinen eigenen Freifunknoten hier aufmachen und dann stehst du da alleine auf weiter Flur. Und insofern, klaro, teilt man dann einfach mal so den Anschluss. Wie gesagt, aktuell verschlüsselt. Nachbar kennt das Kennwort, wählt sich mit ein oder so. Meine Überlegung ist halt, wenn man seinen Access-Brand ganz aufmachen wollte, ob man dann nicht irgendwie sagt, okay, pass mal auf, ich mach da so ein bisschen Paketfilter und sag, also ihr könnt im Web gucken, ihr könnt nem E-Mail schicken und empfangen und Peer-to-Peer sperrt man da einfach mal oder so, ohne jetzt den Traffic selbst anzugucken.
Das ist natürlich prinzipiell möglich, aber ich weiß nicht, wie du damit off the shelf, also mit Hardware aus dem Laden, dir das einfach so konfigurieren kannst. Aber vielleicht macht das ja so ein Freifunkbox, vielleicht kann die das einfach?
Ja, die Freifunkboxen haben, wie gesagt, diese Peer-to-Peer-Skripte eingebaut. Es gibt da das ZAP-Skript und das Peer-to-Peer-Ding. Und das muss man dann anmachen. Und kann man auch über seinen eigenen Freifunkrouter surfen. Manchmal ist das auch ganz praktisch. Wenn man hier irgendwie einen Mist macht und das gar nicht merkt, oder irgendwie die kleine Schwester da was installiert hat, was man gar nicht mitgekriegt hat, dann kriegt man plötzlich selbst diese ZAP-Page und merkt so, oops, okay, dann guck ich vielleicht mal, was für Software am Rechner läuft.
Nach dem Motto, das ist ja mein eigener Rechner.
Ich mach das auch eigentlich immer reaktiv. Guck dann einfach, wenn das Netz sich grad mal wieder langsam anfühlt, dann guck ich da bei mir auf die Graphen, welche IP-Adresse, also welcher Teilnehmer da in letzter Zeit zu viel Datenverkehr gemacht hat. Und dann weiß ich auch meistens schon, anhand des Namens des Rechners, wem ich da nochmal an der Tür klingeln muss.
Das fühlt sich jetzt schon noch ein bisschen nach Grenzbereich an, weil du da ja schon wieder ein bisschen auf den Traffic Shields, was ja nach diesem Fernmeldegesetz eigentlich nicht so ganz okay ist.
Ne, Aggregation ist schon okay. Das ist einfach nur die...
Also es geht nicht ums was, es geht ums wie viel.
Genau.
Das ist dann natürlich, dann geht's. Ja, wie gesagt, das wär so mein Modell zu der ganzen Geschichte. Also wie gesagt, wenn jemand fragt, Mensch, kann ich mal kurz ins Netz bei dir oder so, wäre ich auch der Letzte, der sagt, ne, also lass mal lieber oder so. Ich mein, klar, gerade hier auch auf dem Dorf, wie gesagt, kleines Dorf, da kennt man dann auch die Leute, die da potenziell überhaupt erst in die Reichweite kommen. Würde ich auch durchaus weiterempfehlen.
Ich hatte den lustigen Effekt gehabt, als ich war neulich in Südamerika unterwegs und als ich dadurch die Täler gefahren bin mit so einem Bus, war dann irgendwann der GSM-Empfang alle, weil lohnte sich einfach nicht für die drei Leute, die in diesem Tal gewohnt haben, da Funktelefonnetzwerke aufzubauen. Aber hol mir ein Telefon raus, da ist ein offenes W-Lan und konnte meine Mama über Skype anrufen und hat einfach funktioniert. Ich finde es total toll, dass es nicht von der wirtschaftlichen Nützlichkeit abhängt, ob man da Internet hat unterwegs, sondern davon, dass irgendjemand der Meinung ist, ja, hier ist dieser Ort einfach wert genug, dass Leute da einfach ihre Mails lesen können, ihren Internet haben.
Genau. Es ist ja dann auch so ein Commons, so ein Gemeingut, so wie diese gemeinschaftlich genutzte Wiese. Und wenn da jeder ein bisschen nutzt, dann funktioniert das. Und wenn alle zu viel Vieh auf die Riese treiben, dann ist da kein Gas mehr. Und dann funktioniert das für niemanden. Und diesen Umgang mit Gemeingütern, den muss man im Zweifelsfall wieder lernen. Einige Leute können das noch.
Stefan, dir erstmal vielen Dank. Und viel Spaß noch. Tschüss. Und genau zu dem, was du gerade gesagt hast, Alex schreibt Fabian auf Twitter. Kann es sein, dass er zu sehr an das Gute im Menschen glaubt? Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, die müssen wir dann anschließend noch mal ein bisschen diskutieren. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht's gleich weiter.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremblack.
Ich finde wir sollten das singen lernen und das so machen. Chaos Radio. Das hört ihr nämlich heute Abend. Alter, das ist sowas von raus. Wer das gerade gesagt hat, der wird in Zukunft wohl nicht mehr so oft hierher kommen. Außerdem ist noch Alex da von den Freifunkern und wir reden heute darüber, ob es eine sinnvolle Sache ist, ein W-Lan offen zu machen oder nicht. Das Problem an der Sache ist, Prinzip kann man dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden, aber es gibt trotzdem ganz viele Leute, die sagen, hey, eigentlich eine coole Idee. Freifunker machen das dann sogar im ganz großen Maßstab, da haben so ein paar Leute, die haben Internet bei sich zu Hause und sagen, hey, wir teilen das und die bauen dann ganz viele W-Lan-Route über die ganze Stadt auf und damit kann man sogar in Brandenburg, in der DSL-Wüste, ein richtiges Netz bekommen. Wir haben jetzt nicht mehr so richtig viel Zeit, weil um Mitternacht ist ja schon wieder vorbei und wir müssen noch ein paar wichtige News mit euch teilen. Vorher geht es aber noch eine Viertelstunde ungefähr um W-Lan und da ist jetzt der Theo am Telefon, tach.
Ja, hallo, ich habe die Frage, welchen Standard man da jetzt am besten benutzt? Ist das WEP oder welcher ist das?
Da hatte ich vorhin schon angeschnitten. Spülst du noch mal kurz zurück? Also WEP ist tot und durch und kannst du eigentlich innerhalb endlicher Zeit nach mitschneiden von beliebig wenig Datenpaketen, die dir den Schlüssel ausrechnen und deswegen benutzt du einfach WPA, respektive WPA2.
Okay, gut, wir haben noch so einen alten Router und den wollte ich mal wieder in den Betrieb nehmen und also der ist jetzt ein Jahr alt oder so. Wir nutzen meistens irgendwie ein LAN-Kabel und dann ja und dann habe ich noch eine Frage zum Online-Routing, also dieses mit Tor, mit der Endnote, das war jetzt, wenn man halt derjenige ist, der am Ende sitzt oder wie?
Derjenige, von dem aus dann die Pakete zu kommen scheinen, genau.
Okay, das heißt, der dann eventuell angearscht wäre.
Der dann mit einem gewissen Risiko lebt, angearscht zu werden, aber mein Gott, das Leben ist voller Risiken und muss man halt... Muss man halt schon aber noch Lust haben.
Aber ernsthaft, das Leben ist voller Risiken, das kannst du halt sehr entspannt sagen, weil du dich nämlich sehr gut auskennst, wenn einfach jemand zu Hause sitzt und denkt so, hey Tor, geiles Projekt, will ich mitmachen?
Genau, ein Exitnote ist schon für jemanden, der sich vielleicht, deren Rechtsanwalt ziemlich gut kennt und dort auch dann bei ihm Expertise einholen kann, wenn es dann wirklich hart auf hart kommt, ansonsten sollte man sich halt mit dem Tor-Projekt auseinandergesetzt haben, bevor man dort ernsthaft Exitnotes selber betreiben möchte.
Mittelnotes ist dann...
Mittelnotes ist schon eigentlich kritisch.
Gibt da ja auch Leute, die da ein bisschen Unterstützung leisten, da kann der Erdgeist mehr zu erzählen. Wenn man dann wirklich der Meinung ist, man will ein Exitnote betreiben, gibt es da Wege, das so zu machen, dass man nicht gleich irgendwie komplett in der Scheiße sitzt?
Genau, also beim Chaos Computer Club sind auch befreundete Anwälte generell dabei, Tor-Exitnote-Betreibern zu helfen. Wir haben dort schon auch Anwälte, die sich regelmäßig mit Staatsanwaltschaften auseinandersetzen, die denen dann die Briefe zukommen lassen, in denen drin steht. Das ist ein Exitnote und alle Datenverkehr, die du von da gesehen hast, können wir da nicht zuordnen, weil dürfen wir auch nicht mitloggen. Und dann hat sich das erledigt, weil dann haben die Staatsanwaltschaften was zum Wegheften und dann ist es auch okay. Und wer ernsthaft darüber nachdenkt, kann sich an torwarte.ctc.de wenden und dort wird dir dann geholfen.
Es ist ja nun mal so, dass wenn jeder ein Exitnote betreiben würde, dann bräuchte man gar keine Exitnotes. So ein bisschen immer dieses zivile Ungehorsam hin und her, aber diese Welt, in der man halt noch nicht mal irgendwie ein Kaugummi kauen kann, ohne einen Ausweis abzugeben, ist ja auch keine Utopie, in der wir leben wollen. Und je mehr Leute halt so was machen, desto schwieriger ist es halt, das auch zu verfolgen. Es macht gar keinen Sinn, das zu verfolgen. Und wenn jetzt alle ihre W-Lans aufmachen würden, dann könnten alle überall surfen und dann bräuchte man wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Freifunk. Und dann würde es auch gar keine Verfolgung geben, weil jedem klar ist, dass es nichts bringt. Aber dadurch, dass halt irgendwie ganz furchtbar geherzt wurde, oh, ihr müsst alles dicht machen und überhaupt, und euer Jägerzaun reicht nicht. Hier haben wir Selbstschussanlagen, die verkaufen wir euch und zieht doch mal einen fetten Bauzaun um euren Garten, weil es könnte ja jemand bei euch in das Gebüsch pinkeln oder so. Ja und jetzt sind diese Bauzäune da und wer keinen hat, hat den Boomer und dabei ist es eigentlich völlig in Ordnung, einen kleinen Jägerzaun oder gar keinen Zaun zu haben. Und wenn dann jemand vorbeikommt, sich in den Vorgarten setzt und sich die Sonne auf den Bauch scheinen lässt, dann ist es eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Und man kann sich mit dem unterhalten und freut sich, dass man da immer teil hat.
Wenn ich das mal übersetzen darf, du findest offenes WLAN eine gute Idee.
Theo, weißt du Bescheid?
Ich hätte noch eine Frage. VPN, welches Programm da jetzt empfehlenswert ist? Weil ich kenne da so eins, wo irgendwie das Symbol ist mit so einem Typen in der Sonnenbrille und einem Hut oder so. Wobei ich da aber mir, ich fand das irgendwie nicht so seriös.
Welches Betriebssystem benutzt du denn?
Welches Betriebssystem? In der Regel Windows. Aber ich bin jetzt auch schon am Umsteigen auf Linux.
Na, weiß nicht. Ich benutze Tunnelblick unter Mac OS. Ich weiß gar nicht, was gerade der aktuelle, einfach OpenVPN, also wenn du Linux benutzt und dich irgendwie mit deiner Kommandozeile auseinandergesetzt hast, dann würde ich sagen OpenVPN und vielleicht einen grafischen Fripper drumrum. Weiß ich aber auch gerade nicht.
Ich glaube der Ubuntu Network Manager kann inzwischen auch PPTP und OpenVPN-Tunnel konfigurieren.
Okay, das sind sozusagen technische Details, die wir nicht näher erläutern können und wollen. Die kann man sich nachlesen. Aber auf jeden Fall, es geht. Man kann aber sozusagen für Windows nicht eine direkte Empfehlung rausgeben. Falls da jemand am Start ist, bitte 0331-77-97-110 ist die Nummer zu anrufen. Theo?
Es gibt auch noch Hotspot Shield. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch nicht so das Beste, oder? Also das passt für Windows, aber es ist halt, ja, also das ist irgendwie, da surft man dann halt über deren Server, der irgendwo in den USA ist. Und naja, ich weiß nicht, man muss da auch manchmal irgendwelche Banner klicken im Internet, also als Werbung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das ganz so wirklich sicher ist.
Also ich soll hier im IRC ging gerade rum, du sollst mal TAU VPN angucken. Und dann, mehr können wir dir da glaube ich in dem Moment auch nicht empfehlen.
Generell kann man sagen, wenn man irgendwie Banner klicken muss, ist es wahrscheinlich eher komisch und VPN kostet grundsätzlich Geld, wenn es gut funktioniert. Und Software können wir dir jetzt leider nicht direkt weiterhelfen, da müsste man mal tiefer in die Materie einsteigen. Warte, halt, nein, Theo, ich muss dich jetzt leider abwürgen, weil es sind noch vier andere Leute da und die Sendung ist gleich vorbei.
Okay, gut, Dankeschön und schöne Sendung.
Alles klar, bis dann, tschüss.
So, dann haben wir noch den Carsten. Hallo Carsten.
Hallo, ich hab selber ein Freifunknetz in Gardow. Das sind zwei Dörfer, die wir miteinander verbinden, im nördlichen Brandenburg. Ich wollte noch ein bisschen Angst rausnehmen aus der Sendung. Ich hab vor kurzem gelesen bei Heise, dass wenn man bewusst einen öffentlichen W-Lan betreibt, dann kann man maximal mit 100 Euro abgemahnt werden, weil dann die neuen Gesetze greifen. Das nimmt vielleicht ein bisschen Angst, wenn 100 Euro noch überschaubar sind.
Carsten, ich bin mir jetzt nicht 100% sicher, aber ich glaube, du wirfst da ein paar Sachen zusammen, weil um diese 100 Euro ging es tatsächlich mal. Das war aber sozusagen für den Fall, der von BGH verteidigt verhandelt wurde. Das hat aber nichts mit Cafés zu tun. Also, tu mir bitte eingefallen, es gibt dir ein Wiki zur Sendung, chaosradio.de, da findet ihr das. Wenn du diesen Artikel noch mal findest, kannst du den einfach da verlinken, dass man es noch mal selber nachlesen kann? Cool. Bis denn. So, jetzt aber hier schnell und durch. Jan? Tag.
Cool, dass ich durchgekommen bin. Ich habe eine Frage.
Wir müssen uns aber schon jetzt beeilen.
Ja, ich beeile mich ganz schnell. Und zwar habe ich eine ganz einfache Frage. Auf meiner Schule, wir haben ganz viele Rechner und wir dürfen halt in unseren ganzen drei Stunden und Unterricht halt rein, um Medien zu nutzen, haben aber eine fette Internetsperre. Also, keine Ahnung. Man fühlt sich halt wie in China fast. Wir haben, glaube ich, eine normale LAN-Verbindung. Und meine Frage wäre es jetzt, also ich finde dieses, ja, dein Server, also dein Internet freizugeben für andere, für Nachbarn, also eigentlich ziemlich cool. Die Frage ist jetzt, ist es möglich, beispielsweise solche Internetsperren über meinen Provider einzurichten, damit ich den Nachbarn und den ganzen Menschen, denen ich mein Internet ja freigeben möchte, in gewisse Bahnen lenke, also dass ich sage, die Seiten sind gesperrt, da bitte nicht quasi.
Ja, ist es möglich, aber eigentlich unschön. Also du möchtest ja denn, wenn du ihm das Surfen erlaubst, möchtest du nicht sagen, dass er bestimmte Seiten nicht ansurfen darf. Meine Frage ist, ist denn die Volksrepublik China selber irgendwie noch mal ein viel schlimmerer?
Ja, das ist richtig, ja.
Also.
Also es wäre theoretisch möglich. Meine Frage wäre jetzt, es gibt ja keine Ahnung, Parksy-Server, etc. Man ändert einfach den Open DNS, keine Ahnung. Bestimmt genug Möglichkeiten, das einfach zu übergehen. Ich meine, ich plane jetzt nicht. Also ich wohne selber in Brandenburg. Ich hab von Telekom manche W-Lan. Ich bringe dir jetzt nichts wirklich, meinen W-Lan für meine Nachbarn aufzumachen.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich erstens ihr W-Lan empfange und sie selbst es dann nicht habe.
Aber stell dir vor, die haben ganz kurz mal Netzausfall und bei dir gibt es noch Internet in Würden. Die sehen es natürlich auch freundlich, wenn sie bei dir weitestufe finden.
Dazu muss ich aber sagen, ich wohne nicht so weit weg in Brandenburg, aber das ist familiär. Neben mir wohnt mein Cousin, meine Cousine. Wenn die wirklich Internet wollen, dann könnten die quasi rüberkommen. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen abgelenkt. Natürlich wäre ich auch bereit, mein Internet aufzumachen.
Kommen wir zum Punkt?
Kommen wir zum Punkt. Meine Frage wurde ja eigentlich schon beantwortet. Das ist also möglich.
Cool, danke schön. Jan, viel Spaß noch. Tschüss. Wir müssen jetzt leider 24er hier noch im Netz ist und Walli vertrösten, weil es neigt sich dem Ende zu. Es gibt noch eine Frage aus dem Chat, die ich stellen wollte, die heißt Alex Freifunk an Schulen und öffentlichen Einrichtungen. Gibt es da irgendwie Erfahrungen? Machen das Leute oder ist das zu nerdig?
Ne, das ist nicht zu nerdig. Ich bin da natürlich nicht über die Details informiert. Da gibt es den Ulf, der an der Datenschule glaube ich in Friedrichshain da ein Projekt mitgemacht hat, das ganz erfolgreich ist. Da müsste ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Okay, es gibt ja das Wiki zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. Kannst du da einfach reinschreiben, an wen man sich wenden muss?
Da schreibe ich das rein. Auf jeden Fall weiß ich, dass es mehrere Schulen gibt, die bereits Projekte mit Freifunk machen und das sehr erfolgreich ist.
Alles klar. Jetzt machen wir das Typische, was nie funktioniert. Ihr habt jetzt beide 30 Sekunden, um die Sendung abzuschließen. Also die famosen letzten Worte quasi.
Es gab wohl die Frage, ob ich die Welt nicht zu naiv sehe. Wahrscheinlich. Aber ich möchte einfach, dass die Menschen sich lieb haben und aus einer Toilette trinken können, ohne Ausschlag zu kriegen. Und deswegen freie Netze für alle.
Also wie sagte jemand, Weltherrschaft durch freie Netze ist völlig langweilig. Wir wollen Chaos und Anarchie durch freie Netze. Wenn irgendwie die Leute mal Rückgrat hätten, dann wären wir irgendwie alle viel freier. Angst essen Seele auf, keine Angst haben, ist echt cool. Und Freifunk statt Angst und Vorwärtsleute.
Okay, die Meinung ist klar, die beiden Herren hier vertreten haben, freie Netze sind eine coole Idee. Was ich aus der Sendung mitgenommen habe, ist, freie Netze sind eine coole Idee. Allerdings, jetzt einfach so aufmachen, ohne groß nachzudenken, ist nicht so eine coole Idee. Das heißt, wenn ihr das macht, dann informiert euch vorher wirklich, was ihr tut. Also wenn ihr jetzt euer W-Lan wirklich aufmachen wollt, dann lest nochmal genau nach, was kann da passieren, was kann mir drohen. Wenn ihr es zumachen wollt, macht es richtig zu, wenn ihr jetzt WPA2 und wenn ihr bei Freifunk mitmachen wollt, dann ist das alles kein Problem, weil da gibt es monatliche und wöchentliche Treffen und Webseiten, wo man sich alles belesen kann. Aber nicht einfach machen, sondern informieren, gilt ja irgendwie auch schon für so viele Dinge im Leben. Wir schließen jetzt diesen Teil des Chaosradios, wo es ums W-Lan geht. Wir bedanken uns auch für eure Anrufe und eure Geschichten und eure Fragen und müssen jetzt nochmal kurz umschwenken, weil heute eine Nachricht herausgekommen ist, die gerade im Umfeld von Leuten, die mit Software und Patenten zu tun haben, sehr viel Unmut erregt hat. Da möchte der Herr Erdgeist uns jetzt noch etwas zum Besten geben. Herr Erdgeist.
Das sah wohl so aus, als dass das BGH heute eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, die der Firma Siemens ein eingereichtes Trivial-Patent zugesprochen hat, was durch mehrere Instanzen musste und jetzt eigentlich Tür und Tor geöffnet hat, was eigentlich Konsens war, dass diese Software-Patente eigentlich nicht gut sind, dass die den Wettbewerb gerade für kleinere und gerade in Deutschland wichtige Software schmieden, abwirken. Diese Software-Patente, denen wurde heute mit diesem Urteil Tür und Tor geöffnet. Es ging darum, einfach ein trivial beschriebenes Protokoll zum als XML wegschreiben von Daten, würde ich es zusammenfassen.
Okay, darf ich auch mal versuchen zu erklären?
Na gut.
Okay, es ging darum, dass Siemens hat ein Patent angemeldet für eine Software, die jetzt Dinge macht, die nicht wirklich derbe kompliziert sind. Sie haben in zwei Gerichtsverfahren wurde gesagt, ne, das ist kein Patent, das könnt ihr euch mal gefälligst knicken, sind bis von BGH damit gezogen und der hat das jetzt sozusagen gesagt, okay, ihr kriegt doch ein Patent darauf. Insbesondere hat er auch gesagt, dass man auf jedes Computerprogramm ein Patent bekommen kann, nämlich wenn die Lösung gerade darin besteht, ein Datenverarbeitungsprogramm so auszugestalten, dass es auf die technischen Gegebenheiten der Datenverarbeitungsanlage Rücksicht nimmt. Heißt, wenn man ein Programm schreibt, das auf einem Computer läuft, dann kann man das auch patentieren lassen. Das heißt doch jetzt aber sozusagen, um weitergedachten Schluss, ich kann jetzt alle Software patentieren lassen. Und das führt dann dazu, dass jetzt irgendwie die Firmen dann losrennen werden und alles patentieren, dann kann man selber keine Programme mehr schreiben, oder was sagen, warum ist das so schlimm?
Na, weil große Firmen ja generell diese Patente einfach als große Mengen davon sammeln und dann einfach beim Konkurrenten, der ihnen grad nervt, nachschauen, ob sie da irgendwas, was so ähnlich klingt, verletzt haben. Und dann ist, wenn der Konkurrent groß genug ist, dann gucken die in ihr Patentportfolio, was haben wir denn da? Und dann gibt es da so Nicht-Angriffspakte, dass man irgendwie sagt, ja gut, dann müssen wir uns nicht gegenseitig verklagen, sondern ihr habt genug Patente, wir haben genug Patente, wir können sie irgendwie einfach gegenseitig nutzen. Und die gearschten sind dann halt die kleinen Spieler, so kleinere Softwarefirmen, die dann einfach kein Programm mehr implementieren können, was standardtriviale Technologien benutzt, ohne in einen furchtbaren Patentsumpf zu versacken, um vorher sich Erkundigungen einholen zu müssen, ob irgendwas, was sie da gerade implementiert haben, ob das schon irgendjemand anders patentiert hat, selbst bei den trivialsten Dingen. Also ein beliebtes Beispiel ist einfach der Maus-Cursor, der irgendwie alles was drunter ist, einfach stumpf X-Ord, also so invertiert, was auf dem Bildschirm ist. Und das war patentiert gewesen und das konnte man dann einfach nicht implementieren, ohne sich dort um die Patentenässe hinzusetzen. Und wenn solche Patente erlassen werden, dann kann man hier eigentlich den mittelständischen Softwarehandwerk einfach gleich ins Grab schubsen.
Das heißt, das würde nicht mehr funktionieren. Jetzt ist das ja vor dem BGH verhandelt worden und es gibt eine Urteile vom BGH. Das ist ja irgendwie die höchste Instanz. Ich meine, die Meldung ist neu, es gibt wahrscheinlich noch keinen großen Plan, aber was ist der Schritt, der da gemacht wird von den Leuten, die protestieren wollen?
Also ihr? Ich hab offen gestanden, gerade erst auf dem Weg ins Studiolöffner fahren und hatte noch nicht so richtig viel Zeit zur Recherche und wir werden da jetzt einfach mal diskutieren müssen, was wir dagegen tun und wahrscheinlich versuchen politisch dagegen noch vorzugehen.
Gab es so ein Fall schon mal?
So ein Fall in Deutschland.
Dass man das BGH in Entscheidung getroffen hat, wo ihr gesagt habt, so geht es aber nicht. Wenn ich jetzt an die letzten Sachen denke, Wahlcomputer, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da war das BGH ja immer so, das Bundesverfassungsgericht war. Da war das B verfallen.
Was geht da jetzt?
Man kann schauen, ob man es noch übers Bundesverfassungsgericht oder EGH in höherer Instanz entscheiden lässt. Aber da sind wir gerade als Club noch nicht involviert. Das sind ja gerade die Firmen, die das gewesen ist, die dort noch Prozesspartner sind. Da müsste man wahrscheinlich erst schauen, ob man das noch rechtlich anzugreifen kann. Aber ich bin kein Anwalt und deswegen...
Wieso nicht?
Ich hab mich im Alter von 12 Jahren hinter meinem Rechner verschanzt und gemeint, das ist spannender als Recht.
Nicht wieder auf eurem Bein.
So, und das war's?
Und nun? Du wolltest so Musik machen.
Nein, nein, so geht's nicht. Damit werden wir uns in Zukunft beschäftigen. Gibt es sonst noch was, was jetzt ansteht? Also Chaos Computer Club mäßig in der nächsten Zeit?
Ja, es gibt zum Jahresende einen Kongress.
Aber wir werden ja bald.
Und die neue Datenschleuder wird diese Woche in den Druck gehen. Und die nächste Woche bei den Abonnenten landen.
Und wenn man die noch nicht hat, was macht man dann?
Dann muss man die schnell abonnieren.
Gut.
So, und Alex von den Freifunkern? Letzte Gelegenheit, schamlos Werbung zu machen?
Ja, wir haben dann dieses mit kommende Woche des Wireless Battle Mesh. Das ist eine sportliche Veranstaltung, bei der Routing-Protokolle gegeneinander antreten, dürfte den durchschnittlichen Fußball-Fan auch interessieren, wenn dann Batman, OLSR und Babel in Italien auf einem Campingplatz mit 50 Routern gegeneinander antreten.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Die bewerbt man sich dann oder?
Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass da jede Menge Nerds zusammenkommen und ganz viele Router mit Software bespielen und dann nochmal und nochmal, bis das dann klappt. Und die verteilen sie dann auf diesem Campingplatz und dann fangen sie an, die einzuschalten und versuchen, Daten von einem Ende zum anderen zu bringen. Und das Routing-Protokoll, was das am besten kann, das hat gewonnen. Das ist das Battlemash.
Da wird sozusagen die Geschwindigkeit gemessen wie?
Da wird die Geschwindigkeit gemessen und wie schnell fängt das an zu funktionieren und wie reagiert es auf Störungen und welches kommt mit den Störungen klar und welches mit den Störungen und die Programmierer sind alle da und fixen ganz viele Bugs. Und das Ganze ist auch noch an der Adria in der Nähe von Rom. Und dann hat man irgendwie abends ganz viel Spaß und trinkt ganz viel Wein und lernt sich kennen.
Dazu muss man nach Italien fahren. Jetzt sag noch mal kurz, wenn man sich für Freifunk interessiert, wo muss man dann hierhin kommen, wo geht man hin?
Es gibt jeden Mittwoch das Treffen der Freifunker in der Raumstation unter Berlin. Das ist die Seabase. Die sind in der Runge, Straße 20. Und du hast es heute verpasst. Ich habe es heute verpasst. Ich musste meinen Einsatz für Freifunk hier irgendwie absolvieren. Ja, und das ist furchtbar gemütlich. Und jeden ersten im Monat gibt es dort das Einsteiger, den Einsteiger-Workshop. Und dann gibt es gelegentlich auch noch fortgeschrittene Vorträge. Und da kann man hin. Und das sind ganz friedliche, die beißen auch nicht. Und die zeigen einem dann auch alles und sagen, guck mal hier, da ist schon ein Punkt auf der Karte ganz in der Nähe, wo du wohnst. Nimm noch mal dieses Gerät mit gegen ein bisschen Fund. Und dann kannst du das mal ausprobieren. Ja, und helfen halt und integrieren dich. Und sagen dir, guck mal, da ist auch ein lokaler Treffpunkt. Wie der Keks, der dann in Berlin Nordost sitzt und da irgendwie im Herberts mit seinen Kumpels Freifunk macht. Und ja, das sind so die Anknüpfpunkte. In Friedrichshain gibt es eine Gruppe und in Kreuzberg. Ansonsten sind wir natürlich auf dem Chaos Communication Congress.
Jahresende, da warten wir noch ein bisschen.
Aber morgen ist Chaos Computer Club Berlin der offene Donnerstag, wo natürlich wieder alle Hörer aus dem Einzugsgebiet eingeladen sind, einfach zu kommen, mal zu schnuppern und zu schauen. Die Nerds dort beißen auch nicht.
Das versprechen Sie immer. Ich habe mich selber schon davon überzeugen können. Ich bin bis jetzt ohne Bisswunne davon gekommen. Sie danken also euch erstmal, euch beiden hier, die ihr da wart, fürs Chaosradio und auch allen Leuten, die angerufen und mitgemacht haben. Und das Chaosradio gibt es natürlich auch als Podcast wahrscheinlich noch im Laufe der Nacht unter fritz.de und dann später auch auf chaosradio.de in offiziellen und offiziellen Mitschnitten in jeglicher Choleur. Ihr könnt euch also aussuchen, was ihr wollt. Ich übergebe jetzt an Smiths und Smart. Die machen den Nerdflight. Die waren heute abends um acht noch im Cottbus, um Musik gegen Nazis zu machen. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was für Musik, ist eigentlich auch egal, weil der Grund reicht schon genug. Außerdem waren sie auf dem Stress-Festival. Ich bin ja auch ganz im Stress. Und werden jetzt im Nerdfight in drei Stunden dieses Festival noch mal reviveln und euch die Musik mitbringen, die sie da gespielt und gehört haben. Ich wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß. Die Sage macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.